ennemi c'est nous
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur arte france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités toujours tenus à bonne
distance et nos reporters voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce mardi 7
juillet emmanuel macron a fixé quatre
grands axes de travail dont la
reconstruction du pays et le patriotisme
républicain au gouvernement qu'il a
réuni pour la première fois aujourd'hui
lors du conseil des ministres le nouveau
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
avec une première journée mouvementée
avec plusieurs manifestations de
militantes féministes qui appelle à sa
démission en raison d'accusations de
viol à son encontre
l'assassinât de saleilles magny jugées
illégales selon une experte de l'onu le
général iranien avait été tué en janvier
dernier sur le sol irakien par un drone
américain
un rapport mandaté par l'onu parle de
l'absence de menace imminente mettant en
danger la vie à un nouveau désaveu pour
washington qui ne devrait pas arranger
sa relation avec téhéran
en bolivie le parquet réclame pour la
deuxième fois l'arrestation d'evo
morales le procureur général accuse
l'ancien président bolivien réfugiés en
argentine de délit présumé le terrorisme
et de leur financement et de manche son
arrestation
[Musique]
tous les regards sont désormais tournés
vers le nouveau gouvernement son premier
conseil des ministres a eu lieu dans
l'après-midi exercice connu pour
beaucoup d'entre eux qui ont gardé leur
portefeuille comme bruno le meilleur le
maire florence paris ou encore jean yves
le drian ils travailleront désormais
avec huit nouveaux entrants le premier
ministre jean castex a donné le tempo il
veut aller vite
place au travail donc pour la nouvelle
formation retrouve notre reporter et
celle farges devant l'elysée bonsoir
estelle alors après les passations
convoi avant ce matin place désormais à
l'action avec le conseil des ministres
qui vient de s'achever il ya tout juste
quelques minutes
pas exactement place aux travaux
pratiques aujourd'hui avec le tout
premier conseil des ministres du
gouvernement castex quitté qui s'est
achevé il n'y a pas à quelques minutes
mais trois heures la nouvelle équipe
composée de seize ministres 14 ministres
est délégué d'un secrétaire d'état s'est
réunit donc elle cet après midi aux
tourrades emmanuel macron pendant 1h45
le couple exécutif macron à castex qui
souhaite accélérer la cadence et montrer
que l'équipe est opérationnel à l'issue
du conseil a s'est tenu le traditionnel
contre compte-rendu tenue pas pour la
première fois à part gabriel at-elle le
porte parole du gouvernement qui a
évoqué une équipe de combat et de
rassemblement avec un nouveau chemin qui
s'articule autour de quatre grands axes
la reconstruction du pays d'abord
reconstruction économique social
environnemental et territorial et
culturel puis le patriotisme républicain
je propose d'ailleurs à d'écouté à ce
propos gabriela talent
le deuxième axe de ce nouveau chemin
c'est le patriotisme républicain
parapublic a parfois trop manqué à
manquer à ses propres promesses et donc
nous allons avancer avec des objectifs
clairs aller au bout de notre ambition
sur l'école qui a démarré je le disais
avec le dédoublement des classes porté
par jean michel bancaire il nous faut
poursuivre dans ce mouvement
c'est un défi historique pour notre
jeunesse qui a vécu un moment
extrêmement difficile avec le
confinement et sur laquelle nous devons
continuer à investir et des annonces
seront faites autour de ce sujet pour
l'avenir de notre jeunesse
le porte parole du gouvernement qui a
aussi évoqué la volonté du chef de
l'état d'avoir une politique plus est
visible ainsi qu'une politique
européenne forte
notez enfin que jean castex réunira s
ministre dans un séminaire
gouvernemental samedi matin merci est el
farj en direct depuis l'elysée ou plutôt
devant l'elysée effectivement puisque rt
n'est toujours pas accrédité à l'elysée
comme vous le savez et en marge de la
passation de pouvoir entre christophe
castaner et gérald darmanin plusieurs
faits me sont venues manifester une
dizaine de personnes ont crié des
slogans et brandi des pancartes contre
le nouvel homme fort de la place beauvau
gérald darmanin qui je le rappelle est
visé par une plainte pour viol elles ont
été rapidement repoussés et empêcher de
se rapprocher par les forces de l'ordre
dont les échos on aimerait déjà qu'ils
écoutent les associations
notamment dans le cadre des féminicides
par exemple qu'il ya une formation de la
police en fait surtout apprendre les
portes ça c'est une demande qu'il y a je
ne sommes pas écoutés on a employé des
moyens quand même assez massive de
collage et réseaux sociaux
même à l'international le mouvement
décollage s'est beaucoup démocratisé et
aujourd'hui le gouvernement qui avait
annoncé sa volonté de faire de l'égalité
femmes-hommes la grande poésie
quinquennat nous montre l inverse par
les actes et pogab riel attal le nouveau
porte parole du gouvernement le principe
de la présomption d'innocence s'applique
à gérald darmanin écouter la question de
les investigations sur gérald darmanin
sur ce sujet moi ce que je veux dire de
manière très claire c'est que on ne peut
pas d'un côté sacraliser la présomption
d'innocence en toutes circonstances et
considérer que c'est un socle essentiel
de notre pays ce qui est notre cas je
crois et je l'espère à tous et
considérer qu'il y aurait des personnes
qui par la fonction qu'elle occupe ne
pourraient pas bénéficier de cette
présomption d'innocence il ya des
investigations
elles se tiennent et c'est normal on est
en état de droit mais mais mais on peut
parler plus loin que ça en considérant
que finalement parce qu'il ya des
investigations il y aurait il y aurait
des impossibilités à exercer dans un
gouvernement
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
fatima benomar militante associations
féministes les effrontés bonsoir fatima
menouar merci d'être avec nous alors on
l'a vu en plusieurs féministes qui sont
venus manifester en marge de la
passation de pouvoir entre christophe
castaner et gérald darmanin c'était
important selon vous de mettre la
pression dès le premier jour oui
effectivement ça a été une première
réaction un peu pulsionnel il ya eu deux
rassemblements rien qu'aujourd'hui
et c'est vrai qu on n'attendait pas
grand chose des politiques publiques
contre les violences faites aux femmes
on a assez dit que tout ce qui s'était
passé au moment du grenelle c'était très
peu de moyens pour beaucoup de
communication mais au moins au moment du
grenelle contre les violences faites aux
femmes
le gouvernement avait admis qu'ils
avaient deux grands secteurs où il y
avait un réel problème c'était la police
et la justice qui était dans le parcours
des femmes victimes de viols et de
violences conjugales et de violences
sexuelles et c'est parce que les
policiers ne prenez pas les plaintes
parce que nous allions des qualifiés le
viol ont lu des qualifiant en agression
sexuelle parce que ce sont des
classements sans suite à gogo faut
savoir qu'en france au plus haut niveau
de l'état on admet qu'il ya qu'un pour
cent des violeurs qui sont condamnés et
le premier remaniement après le grenelle
en cdd qui aura lieu à voir des gestes
forts c'est-à-dire au moins à la tête de
la police et de la justice des personnes
qui sont sensibilisés sur ces questions
là et là on a exactement l'inversé
on a comme premier flic de france un
homme qui est accusé par deux femmes de
viol et pas n'importe quelle forme de
viol c'est-à-dire des femmes qui disent
qu'il a abusé de postes de pouvoir
en tant que maire et entente et
personnes en responsabilité à l'ump pour
monnayer entre guillemets contre des
rapports sexuels des services qu'elle
lui demander et on a de l'autre côté à
la tête pendant que garde des sceaux un
homme ouvertement anti féministe je vous
passe les tirs à a2
revenir pardonnez-moi fatima génome
aaron va revenir sur le cas de monsieur
dupont moretti
dans quelques instants à londres dans
l'ordre si vous le voulez bien
concernant gérald darmanin vous dites
voilà accusations de viol effectivement
il ya une enquête mais gabriel atta le
porte parole du gouvernement nous
rappelle effectivement le pouvoir de
bénéficier de la présomption d'innocence
qui prévaut dans notre droit français ça
ne veut rien dire en vous la présomption
d'innocence dans le doute on s'abstient
et on n'est pas ministre c'est ça en
tout cas quand on nomme des ministres
on ne discrimine pas si on n'aime pas
certaines personnes c'est la discrétion
du pouvoir c'est à dire que un chef de
l'état qui choisit des ministres selon
les messages qui vous envoyer la
population selon les politiques qu'il
veut mener s'il ya une personne déjà ça
fait plusieurs semaines on était même
les avocats de la plaignante de monsieur
darmanin disent que c'est assez
scandaleux je suis d'accord avec elle
que le gouvernement exprime bruyamment
son soutien à d'arbres afin que ce soit
madame sibat ndiaye qui était porte
parole du gouvernement
où que ce soit nicole belloubet qui
avait même rajouté cette phrase
incroyable
au demeurant c'est un très bon ministre
ça n'a rien à voir avec la choucroute
excusez-moi l'expression mais là c'est à
dire que le président assume d'émettre
un poste absolument stratégique et un
poste de pouvoir suprême un homme qui
est visé par des femmes c'est à dire que
rien que le fait de lui donner à ce
point sa confiance il est déjà en train
d'accuser les accusatrices de mentir et
c'est pas comme ça on va peut-être pas
les sur le fond du dossier mais c'est
pas beau c'est qu'il est vide c'est un
dossier où il ya des échanges sms ou
barman 1,10 à sa victime
comment je fais pas ça pour me faire
pardonner c'est bien qu'il ya quelque
chose à se faire pardonner
alors je vais bien la présomption
d'innocence à ce moment là moi je dis
pas ils attendent la fin des
investigations mais au moins
et pendant ce temps là pendant qu'il ya
présomption d'innocence mais aussi
possibilité que ces femmes qui ne se
sont pas concertés dise la vérité tout
simplement qu'il se s'abstiennent de
risquer de mettre au premier flic de
france
un homme qui abusent
situation de pouvoir pour imposer des
rapports sexuels en tout cas là pour nos
téléspectateurs sachez que la cour
d'appel de paris a demandé la reprise
des investigations le 11 juin et quant à
gérald darmanin lui il confirme avoir eu
une relation sexuelle avec la plaignante
mais selon lui librement consentis vous
aviez commencé à parler du nouveau
ministre de la justice monsieur dupont
moretti
là encore vous n'est pas enchanté par
cette nomination
absolument pas monsieur moretti ne s'est
jamais caché de ses opinions
profondément anti féministe avec
vraiment un discours qui incarne tout ce
qu'on dénonce par rapport à ce qu'on
appelle la culture du viol c'est-à-dire
que quand il dit une faute d'une femme
à 30 ans on n'est plus une potiche
incapable de dire non et ben désolé
monsieur moretti j'accompagne des
milliers de victimes
on a assez produits de travaux sur les
systèmes de sidération
et oui il ya des femmes puis dans des
situations d'emprise ou des situations
de supérieurs hiérarchiques public qui
leur imposent des comportements
absolument déplacé sur leur lieu de
travail
effectivement on peut avoir beaucoup de
mal à se défendre
je passe sur les commentaires sur l'
affaire dsk ce sont des copains qui
s'offrent du bon temps je rappelle quand
même que c'était une affaire assez
lourde de proxénétisme ou en ramener des
personnes en situation de prostitution
où dsk avait dit lui même devant les
juges c'est vrai que j'ai été très
brutal où ils s'envoyaient des sms en
parlant de ces jeunes ferment ciation
prostitution en disant est ce que tu
ramènes du matériel etc etc
quand l affaire de georges tron il ya
une femme qui dit la plaignante qui dit
lors de l'entretien d'embauché
j'ai dit que je savais faire de la
réflexologie et que son commentaire
s'est désolé mais quand une femme dit ça
c'est qu'il est là pour pécho je cite
ses 7 aces ces termes exacts c'est à
dire que en gros il gay elle l'a bien
cherché une femme n'a pas apparu de
réflexologie ou de massage à ce moment
là elle n'a pas se plaindre plus tard de
viol ou d'agression sexuelle qu'elle
peut subir c'est quand même extrêmement
nob
et encore tout à l'heure il était en
train de nous dire pendant la passation
de pouvoir la justice ne seront pas dans
la rue ni sur les réseaux sociaux ni
dans les médias
certes elle se rend ou en france elle ne
se rend pas dans les tribunaux puisqu'on
estime au plus haut de l'état comme je
disais tout à l'heure qui a qu'un pour
cent des violeurs qui sont condamnés il
ya un vrai problème et sans les réseaux
sociaux et sambi tout oser me dire que
monsieur bailly chan serait aux gens de
plus condamné osé me dire que monsieur
matzneff qui pas encore il n'ya pas
longtemps le copain de toute
l'intelligentsia aurait été enfin
conspué comme il le mérite
jamais sans la pression des féministes
de la rue et tout ce qui s'exprime et un
moment dans les réseaux sociaux avec
mitsou avec des millions de femmes qui
exprimait en direct les viols qu'elles
ont vécu le harcèlement sexuel jamais le
gouvernement le soir et ne s'en seraient
emparés donc un moment me suis mort et
il devrait admettre avec humilité et il
fait l'inversé les inquiète beaucoup qui
a un réel problème au niveau de la
justice quant à la condamnation des
viols des violences et merci fatima
benomar d'avoir été avec mon militante
associations féministes les effrontés
eric dupond-moretti on en parle est un
lomo 150 acquittement ce n'est pas une
surprise de voir un avocat garde des
sceaux ce qui l'est en revanche c'est de
voir à quel point sa nomination ne plaît
pas non plus au syndicat majoritaire
chez les magistrats le sm pour eux sont
entrés au gouvernement est tout
simplement une déclaration de guerre et
grégoire xii c'est avec clémence pitel
monsieur eric dupond moretti
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
c'est une annonce pour le moins
surprenante
le visage d'eric dupond-moretti n'est
pas inconnu du grand public associés à
une multitude d'un fer médiatique
cette figure célèbre de la justice
française manie l'art du contre-pied
tour à tour défenseur du couple balkany
bernard tapie jérôme kerviel ou encore
des sportifs nikola karabatic et karim
benzema
celui qu'on surnomme acquittator est
plutôt du genre à aller à contre-courant
dans l'opinion majoritaire ce sobriquet
il le doit un palmarès fourni en
acquittements obtenus pour ses clients
plus de 150 au total la nomination du
successeur de nicole belloubet a de quoi
surprendre tant il entretient des
rapports tourmentée avec les
institutions fin juin
dupond moretti dépose plainte contre x
mécontent d'avoir été mis sous
surveillance par le parquet national
financier une plainte désormais retiré
annonce l'elysée sa nomination à la
justice suscite des réactions pour le
moins mitigé pour moraliser l'action
politique lutter contre le terrorisme et
restaurer la confiance de la police
emmanuel macron nomme ministre de la
justice l'avocat d'abdelkader meira
ainsi que de messieurs mme balkany et
cahuzac
rappelons qu'un avocat peut toujours
choisir ses clients un gouvernement
libéral banal castaner belloubet honte
de l'intérieur de la justice enfin
démissionner darmanin dupond-moretti
doivent rétablir la dignité et l'honneur
félicitations à notre confrère eric
dupond-moretti dont l'engagement dans la
profession n'est plus à démontrer
gageons que les avocats et la justice
retrouveront avec lui la place centrale
qu'ils doivent avoir dans notre
démocratie et notre état de droit
nommer une personnalité aussi clivante
et qui méprise à ce point les magistrats
c'est une déclaration de guerre à la
magistrature
quel est le message qu'entend plus le
ministre de la justice se trouve relégué
aussi loin dans l'ordre protocolaire le
mépris le plus total pour la justice au
lendemain des nominations eric dupond
moretti doit déjà faire face à la colère
des robes noires
à vis de la réforme des retraites le
nouveau ministre de la justice assure
qu'il sera le garde des sceaux du
dialogue ce n'est pas le ministère de la
guerre même si j'ai cru entendre ces
mots mais celui des libertés pendant
près de 36 ans j'ai sillonné la france
dont je connais tous les tribunaux
ah je le confesse je n'ai pas de la
justice une connaissance technocratique
je la connais humainement j'ai appelé
intimement
je la connais nicole charnellement
récemment interrogé sur ce qu'il ferait
s'il devenait garde des sceaux dupond
moretti avait déjà quelques idées
concrètes
d'abord il faut qu'on sépare le siège du
parquet pour moi c'est impératif
je fais le ménage là-dedans de façon
très très très clair je fais un système
de responsabilité des juges parce que
les juges ne sont pas responsables de ce
qu'ils font aujourd'hui ce sont les
seuls dans notre société à ne pas être
responsable il faut réunir des juges et
faire une réforme non pas contre eux
mais avec eux avec des grands juges qui
font l'unanimité parmi les autres
dossiers brûlants prévu à ce nouvel
agenda la réforme du droit pénal
concernant la délinquance
environnementale ou encore le nouveau
code pénal pour mineurs initiée par sa
prédécesseure
alors eric dupond moretti est il un bon
choix pour la justice c'est la question
de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec david
biraud porte-parole jeunesse de la
france insoumise bonsoir david guiraud
merci d'être avec nous à ses côtés
julien odoul membre du bureau national
du rassemblement national bonsoir à vous
aussi
julien odoul alors eric dupond moretti
qui disait qu'il n'accepterait jamais le
poste de ministre de la justice
qu'est ce qui l'a fait changer d'avis
selon-vous emmanuel macron par exemple
qui a su convaincre julien odoul je ne
sais pas ce qui a fait changer d'avis un
monsieur dupont moretti qui dernièrement
oui manifesté toute sa répulsion pour
fait ministère et pour la politique en
général
mais plus généralement moi ce qui
m'inquiète sur ce choix c'est que ça
dénote finalement la vision de la
justice des monnaies de macron mêmes
macron choisi un ministre qui est un
militant d'extrême gauche et qui est un
militant d'extrême gauche qui a une
vision de la justice totalement partial
et je dirais antidémocratique
je rappellerai que monsieur dupont
moretti il ya quelques années en 2015
donc disais qu'il fallait interdire le
front national d' interdire donc le
premier parti d'opposition interdire 11
millions de français donc qui pensent
que marine le pen serait la plus à même
de diriger notre pays
je trouve ça extrêmement graves comme
signal de désigner cette personne donc
comme ministre de la justice et
responsable donc de l'impartialité de
l'état de droit
en tout cas en plus il yad autres
évidemment d'autres état de fait qui ont
jalonné la carrière et du moins
dernières années notamment sa
fascination pour la défense d'abdelkader
meira donc il était très très fier de
défendre donc abdelkader meira la façon
dont il a traité des camps d âge les
soutiens des familles des victimes
juives de l'attentât de toulouse en les
traitant d'extrémistes juifs qui
souhaitaient le bordel enfin voilà du
pot
eric dupond moretti c'est ça c'est de la
violence verbale c'est comment dirais-je
c'est une personnalité extrêmement
clivante
on le voit d'ailleurs avec un stock de
réactions hostiles de la part des
magistrats et surtout voilà c'est
surtout une justice extrêmement laxiste
au sien puisque c'est dans la continuité
de madame belloubet un jeu direct
eric dupond-moretti va creuser encore la
tombe de la justice que ce choix avec le
retour des jihadistes français que ce
soit avec la libération on attendait
c'est un jeune traiter tous les thèmes
des débats
on sent une eau à l'essai ce témoin il y
en a beaucoup et là je suis d'alors
david biraud il ya eu plusieurs idées
véhiculées effectivement par julien ans
d'où l'on va tenter des les prendre dans
l'ordre effectivement voilà
et il a été accusé eric dupond moretti
dès sa nomination par marine le pen 1 du
rassemblement national auquel appartient
julien odoul de militants d'extrême
gauche qui veut interdire le rn déjà sur
ce point est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ce diagnostic vous on est plus pour
interdire le rassemblement national dont
on disait qu'il ya une époque où il
fallait l'interdire ou ces gens étaient
des anciens putschistes des anciens de
l'oas organisation armée secrète qui
voulait renverser le général de gaulle
d'ailleurs ça me fait rire que marine le
pen
ay ay lui rendre hommage alors que les
gens qui ont fondé le front national
était affilié à des anciens nazis
bon mais sur thur dupond moretti
bon en ce moment on parle que de lui
mais parce qu'on ne voit que lui parce
qu'il ya que lui avoir dans ce
remaniement faut commencer par dire ça
faut pas tomber aussi dans ce piège là
on nous annonce et je vous rappelle des
corps aux prises à droite des grosses
prises à gauche des gens qui pèse dans
le milieu institutionnel au final dupont
moretti bas on voit que lui parce que
c'est une sorte de cactus dans le dans
le désert moi quand je vois par exemple
que darmanin et schiappa qui entre au
ministère de l'intérieur pour moi c'est
le début d'une blague c'est pas un
remaniement mais bon sur dupond moretti
je pense que ces gens n'ont pas les
épaules pour ses ministères là et que
c'est dur au kasaï sur dupond-moretti
nous on l'a eu en procès contre nous
contre la france on mise donc évidemment
qu'on va demander des garanties
maintenant j'estime que de toute façon
au niveau du ministère de la justice
pour nous pour la france est soumise en
termes de traitement politique des
opposants ça peut être difficilement
pire que madame b to b
donc moi je rejoins par exemple syndicat
de la magistrature qui en est à demander
des garanties des garanties par rapport
à ce qu'a fait notamment monsieur dupont
moretti en tant qu'avocat qui devaient
pas interférer dans son rôle de ministre
de la 8e' de la justice et ensuite il ya
aussi le programme qu'il a annoncé que
j'ai écouté moi j'ai écouté son discours
je pense que dans son discours il donne
raison à énormément de choses qu'on
disait à la france soumise d'ailleurs
nous n'étions pas la seule organisation
politique a parlé de ça mais parlant sur
l'indépendance de la justice la réforme
du parquet ça fait des années qu'on le
demande parce qu'on sait que les
procureurs sont souvent à charge nous on
a eu un procureur des procureurs sur le
dos à la france a soumises de manière
totalement disproportionnée donc qu'il
avance sur l'indépendance de la justice
ça serait une bonne chose au sein d'un
gouvernement notamment le pib et de ses
équipes qui sont radicalement contre ça
que les enquêtes préliminaires ne soit
pas éternel comme on l'a vu à la france
à smith très récemment
c'est aussi une de nos préoccupations on
espère qu'il va avancer sur ça que le
secret de l'enquète soit respecté ça
c'est une chose à laquelle on tient en
ce moment on est en déclin dans un pays
où le secret de l'enquète n'existe plus
c'est à dire que toujours sa fuite dans
les journaux et les gens n'ont plus
droit à la dignité au respect ça c'est
quelque chose sur lesquels j'attends
monsieur dupont moretti
je viens on va vous redonner la parole
bien sûr david guiraud julien ondes ou
vous qu'est ce qui vous fait le plus
peur parce que vous en avez cité
effectivement voilà beaucoup d'arguments
contre lui qu'est ce qui vous fait le
plus peur avec ce nouveau garde des
sceaux aux arènes ce qui est à craindre
ces deux d'avoir une justice encore plus
politisé qu'elle ne l'était avant avec
mme belloubet et les craintes doivent
être partagés par tous les partis
d'opposition et je partage également le
besoin de garanties de la france
insoumise puisque la france insoumise
aussi a subi les foudres judiciaires on
voit bien qu'on a un pouvoir qui
instrumentalise la justice comme un bras
armé pour taper ces oppositions pour à
chaque fois qu'il y en a une qui devient
un peu trop menaçante et inquiétante bad
actionner ce levier là pour essayer de
les faire fléchir dans tout ça
évidemment avec monsieur dupont moretti
avec ses récentes déclarations
avec son son militantisme anti rn
assumer affirmé évidemment et évidemment
nous fait craindre le pire
ce qui me fait craindre aussi c'est sa
déclaration tout à l'heure donc lors de
la passation de pouvoir de dire que son
ministère sera celui de l'antiracisme
mais on aurait préféré qu'il nous dise
que son ministère sera celui de la fin
du laxisme sera celui du rétablissement
en tout cas la protection de toutes les
libertés des français sera celui de
l'impunité pour les criminels et
délinquants
c'est ça son rôle mais être le ministère
de l'antiracisme l'antiraciste qui
aujourd'hui est devenu un véritable
racisme ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'il va nommer à sa traoré comme porte
parole ou directrice de cabinet qu'elle
est calé ce signal en fait c'est donner
un gage encore une fois aux militants
racialiste à tous les déconstructeurs à
tous ceux qui ces dernières semaines ont
fait tant de mal que ce soit à nos
policiers qui ont essayé déboulonner nos
statuts etc tout ça évidemment c'est un
très mauvais signal et je constate qu'il
est dans la véritablement dans la dans
l'autoroute qui a été un tracé par
nicole belloubet qui a fait beaucoup de
mal à la magistrature qui a fait
beaucoup de mal aux avocats qui étaient
dans la rue
avant la crise jan peter david guiraud
je vois continuité je vous vois lever
les yeux au ciel
effectivement dans le temps on aligne et
julien aux douleurs parlais tout à
l'heure où la de la défense du frère de
mohamed merah c'est en 2017 par maître
dupond-moretti c'est le procès le plus
difficile de ma carrière on a dit que
j'étais c'était la honte de la
profession on a mené c'est mes enfants
mais ça a été pour moi un honneur de le
défendre ça vous inspire quoi vous à la
france a soumis ce genre de déclaration
rappelle mohamed merah qui a tué des
enfants juifs dans une cour d'école
ça vous inspire quoi le problème c'est
pas que monsieur meira soient défendus
moi je pense que c'est un honneur c'est
pas qu'il soit défendu le problème c'est
l'essence même du métier d'avocat mais
qui disent c'est un honneur mais moi je
ne suis pas l'avocat de monsieur dupont
moretti
tout le monde a droit d'être défendu
maintenant ce qui pose problème c'est
les déclarations et les défenses
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que vous avez
vu des aussi des associations notamment
aux féministes qui sont montés au
créneau parce que le poids ne sais pas
qui le défendent en soit c'est les
déclarations qu'il a pu avoir
ou son comportement qui peut être
questionné c'est quand même autre chose
mais voilà mais sinon franchement faut
pas être médias quoi c'est pas dire
qu'on veut être un ministre de la
justice anti raciste c'est quoi la
solution sinon peut être un ministre de
la justice raciste non en bon bah alors
c'est pas ça la déclaration qui devrait
tous nous inquiéter
c'est le fond des réponses qu'il entend
pratiquer ce qu'il aura la desperate
objecté en 1 heure et demie de mener des
réformes de fond moi c'est ça qui
m'intéresse en tant que militant
politique je vais pas m'arrêter à une
déclaration qui pour l'instant n'engage
que lui le respect du secret de
l'enquêté
l'indépendance de la justice indépendant
serait la séparation du parquet et du
siège que que les conditions de vie en
détention soit améliorée parce que
effectivement aujourd'hui ça
il a raison les conditions de vie sont
indignes dans de nombreuses prisons
aujourd'hui voilà ça c'est des vrais
chose en finir avec la surpopulation
carcérale qu'est-ce qu'on fait des gens
qu'on ne met pas dans les prisons c'est
aussi une vraie question qui se pose
pour beaucoup de nos nos concitoyens
c'est normal d'avoir ces débats
c'est sain d'avoir ces débats mais je
veux dire 'ne moi je vais pas suivre
l'extrême droite sur un débat de mots
voilà moi je moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est le fond regardez par exemple en ce
moment l'inspection générale de la
justice enquête sur le parquet national
financier suite
vous savez à la sphère des fans eh ben
c'est à dire des gens qui ont été mis
sous écoute pendant la sphère fillon
sarkozy je sais plus
bush je pense que c'est un énorme
problème ce qu'il s'est passé mais
saisir l'inspection générale de la
justice c'est à dire quelque chose qui
relève du pouvoir exécutif pour enquêter
sur le pouvoir judiciaire c'est un
problème de séparation des pouvoirs le
syndicat de la magistrature demande des
garanties là dessus moi aussi
sur l'un des ponts monde sur les
remontées d'informations vous savez que
la remontée d'informations en ce moment
c'est la remontée d'information du
pouvoir judiciaire vers des gens qui
sont affiliés au pouvoir exécutif ça
c'est une vraie question
parlons des débats de fond soyons
exigeants sur les débats de fond
intraitable mais les questions vraiment
accessoire de dire moi je serais un
ministre antiraciste franchement c'est
ça le débat
merci david guiraud merci également à
julien au double en tout cas pour ce
face à face en direct sur arte france
merci à vous deux dans quelques instants
rester avec nous nous parlerons à du
rapport de l'onu qui qualifie
l'assassinât par les états unis du
général soliman i sur le sol irakien en
janvier dernier d'illégal et puis
direction les bolivie le parquet
bolivien réclament l'arrestation d'evo
morales et est accusé d'actes de
terrorisme
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci nous rejoindre en direct sur rt
france
il est 20h30 heure française
l'assassinât de qassem soleimani par les
états unis sur le sol irakien jugé
illégal
c'est ce qu'a déclaré une rapporteur de
l'onu lors d'un entretien accordé à
l'agencé reuters un nouveau désaveu pour
washington qui ne devrait pas arranger
sa relation avec téhéran ont fait le
point avec walid bennani l'attaqué avait
eu lieu le 3 janvier dernier lors d'une
frappe de drones menées par les états
unis
le général iranien qassem suleimani et
neuf autres personnes sont tuées
la maison blanche avait justifié cet
assassinat ciblé en déclarant qu'il
prépare et des offensives contre des
américains dans la région
six mois plus tard selon l'onu
washington n'a pas apporté de preuves
suffisants d'une attaque en cours ou
imminente contre ses intérêts permettant
de justifier une telle décision
il s'agit d'un moment critique pour le
monde possiblement d'un virage
concernant le recours aux drones
le conseil de sécurité est absent sur ce
sujet tout comme la communauté
internationale qui reste majoritairement
silencieuse selon la rapporteure l'armée
américaine a violé la charte de l'onu
l'expert des droits de l'homme appellent
à plus de régulation et de ses vérités à
propos des frappes de drones
déjà après la tacc l'organisation
internationale pointé du doigt les états
unis aient critiqué l' acte perpétré par
washington sur fond chérien des saisies
pour la syrie il s'agit d'un acte
flagrant est évident d'assassinât
d'agression et d'exécution comme vous
l'avez dit d'une nation étrangère sur
une terre étrangère à un moment où tout
le monde cherche à apaiser les tensions
dans la région et non à les augmenter
ces petits soucis
c'est navrant de voir la grande
puissance des états unis utilisant les
mêmes moyens que les gangs pour tuer
quelqu'un to kill sans brader le général
soliman me qui dirigeait l'unité d'élite
iranienne al-qods joue un rôle important
dans la montée en puissance de l'iran
est dans le conflit contre les forces
américaines sa mort avait eu un impact
majeur dans les relations déjà tendues
entre washington et téhéran l'iran avait
riposté à cet assassinat par des tirs de
missiles contre des bases irakiennes
abritant des soldats américains
le rapport de l'onu sur l'attaqué entre
solesmes à nice sera présenté ce jeudi
au conseil des droits de l'homme et pour
en parler nous sommes avec une affaire
et m a dit journalistes iraniens à rfi
bonsoir nasser et ses manies merci
d'être avec nous alors l'experte inquiet
mandatée par le conseil des droits de
l'homme de l'onu ne s'exprime pas au nom
des états unis c'est important de le
souligner elle doit néanmoins présenté
son rapport devant cette instance jeudi
du coup en conséquence qu'elle est sa
portée juridique
écoutez quand vous venez de le préciser
il ne s'agit pas en fait d'un rapport
officiel de l'eau et nous étendre en
date est seulement par le conseil des
droits de l'homme pour rédiger son
rapport madame calamars doivent
présenter le jeudi devant ce concept et
j'aimerais de faire je préfère de
remarques à ce sujet le première c'est
que le rapport de madame calamars
portent sur nous âge des drones dans les
assassinats ciblés mais la moitié de son
rapport concerne seulement le cas de
l'ancien chef de l'international des
mini site fondé par terrain est dirigée
par lui-même tous rangs des années or
depuis l'instauration de pratiques
assassiné ciblé par dron après les
attentats du 11 septembre 2001 plusieurs
milliers de personnes et pour la plupart
des civils et en particulier au pakistan
et en afghanistan ont perdu de cette
façon laure vit son coeur ou de sa vélo
et nous et encore moins madame calamars
et les déments pressants des victimes et
organisations de défense de droits de
l'homme dénoncent ces pratiques
le deuxième remarque peut-être la plus
étonnante c'est que madame calamars
condamne l'assassinât de rassam slimani
car d'après elle les états unis n'ont
pas justifié à la nécessité de cet
assassinat ou cette exécution
extra-judiciaire dit-elle et n'ont pas
fourni des preuves selon lesquelles des
chefs des forces extérieures des
gardiens de la révolution et représenter
véritable aimant ou menace contre les
intérêts américains en irak ou ailleurs
autrement dit si les américains auraient
présenté ce prof c'est assassinats
ciblés par drones n'aurait pas présenté
aux yeux de madame kala marin vissée
judiciaire or inutile de dire à quel
point ce raisonnement elle fait surtout
lorsqu'il s'agit de la parole d'un haut
commissaire des droits de l'homme du
conseil des droits de l'homme toulouse
alors effectivement les états unis
avaient justifié entre même cet ordre de
le tuer par des attaques imminentes
selon eux contre des diplomates et des
militaires américains on vient de dire à
l'expert elle dit qu'il n'ya pas de
preuves de cela au final qui va devoir
apporter la preuve de ce qu'il avance en
effet le réseau nord est bloqué par
nadine kleinert dans son rapport montre
le décret de la connaissance de sa
connaissance de la situation irakienne
et du rôle des forces qods dont soliman
y était le chef
aussi bien en irak et dans l'ensemble de
la région à moi qu'on a affaire ici à un
rapport écrit impôts sur mesure en vous
je laissais satisfaire etc et l'intérêt
particulier vous savez le côté ironique
de ces rapports c'est que il condamne à
moitié et cela au nom du respect de
droit international
l'assassinât de celui qui a contribué
peut-être le plus à la violation de
droit international de moi dans la
région parce que tout simplement ce les
manies des
c'est pas un enfant du corps il était à
la teda l'international des milices
chiites fondamentalistes ont de la
vice-première a été est resté toujours
la destruction de l'état hébreu
étendre l'influencé iranienne depuis la
péninsule arabique jusqu'à la
méditerranée via l'irak et la syrie
il était une ca kerry l'architecte la
présence militaire iranienne en syrie
depuis 2011 faut réprimer le peuple
syrien et sauver le régime d'assad est
assurée par la même occasion à la
république islamique de devenir fronde
frontalière et d'israël
souleymane sy était à l'origine de la
formation d'amis dix irakiens sur le
modèle 2010 iranien dit pas si j ose
hors de téhéran qui a transformé
c'est vrai grâce à la politique
aberrante et des états unis l'irak en
bassa de régime iranien et à empêcher la
normalisation de la situation irakienne
depuis la chute de saddam aussi faire
seul et même année on imagine que ce
rapport de l'expert de l'onu va mettre
de l'huile sur le feu on sait quel point
ce général soliman y était un symbole en
iran on se souvient des manifestations
ce avaient jeté des millions de gens
bons dont la rue en iran quelles peuvent
être les conséquences
justement de ce rapport entre les
etats-unis et l'iran les rapports entre
les états unis et si tu dis que cette
petite critique
en fait elle n'a pas chiffré le en
focalisant de racine slimani le haut
commissaire des droits de l'homme de
l'onu a choisi croûte est le cas le mot
hasard il ya un sens pour défendre soi
disant droit international à part le cas
aux états unis dont un critique y la
chute de cet ordre c est condamnable et
critiqua mais on n'a pas un rapport de
madame calamars pour pédaler d'ailleurs
l'assassinât parce qu'elle seule est la
question est à savoir internationale si
nous l'ensemble de 2010
it if des états pour faire garantir les
respecter la dignité et les droits de
l'homme où sont la dignité et les droits
des syriens dont le pays était assez
justement par un dictateur sanguinaire
soutenu contre vents et marées en
particulier par la force
roots en vertu de quel droit
international les iraniens et les russes
sont intervenues en syrie pour la
défense de quel droit international le
président turc après avoir chassé
réprimer les courbes au nord de la syrie
en voit maintenant c'est rouge en libye
assassine justement art rond dans un
autre pays
ce qu'ils jugent indésirable ou et on
fait comment pour justifier dans ce
cadre le silence toute l'eau et bout et
madagh club des calamars à ce sujet
méconnu et dans d'autres pays de la
région
merci la servette et m'a dit d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt front en
direction israël à présent et les
territoires palestiniens
les manifestations contre le projet
controversé d'annexion d'une partie de
la cisjordanie se multiplient
éclaircissements avec walid belani un
cratère dans le sol dévastés et des
dégâts matériels multiples symboles du
conflit israélo palestinien
dimanche soir les deux camps se sont
rendus coup pour coup
pour le plus grand désarroi de leur
population qu'un match l'an dernier juan
et non comme vous pouvez le voir les
avions militaires israéliens nous sur
voler de nuit il nous avons été surpris
lorsque les missiles ont commencé à
s'abattre sur nous il semble qu'il
croyait que c'était abriter les membres
de la résistance des missiles ou des
armes mais c'est malheureusement ce que
nous constatons est ce que nous avons
l'habitude de subir de la part des
forces d'occupation
nador à l'alerté là de son côté le
gouvernement israélien s'est tout de
suite justifié en réponse aux trois
roquettes tirées vers israël plus tôt
dans la soirée
nos forces aériennes viennent de frapper
une installation souterraine des
terroristes du hamas à gaza
nous tenons le hamas pour responsable
à hébron les tensions sont également
vives là aussi des manifestants
palestiniens se heurtent aux soldats
israéliens un regain de tensions liées à
la promesse de benyamin nétanyahou
d'opérer le 1er juillet à l'annexion de
pans entiers de la cisjordanie dans le
cadre du plan de paix proposé par donald
trump présenté en janvier dernier à
washington
mais pour l'heure pas d'annoncé
officielle cela aurait pu avoir lieu
mercredi 1er juillet mais les choses
doivent encore se préciser avec le
gouvernement américain
il n'y a pas eu d'accord complet sur les
zones où la souveraineté israélienne
sera appliqué à plan de paix rejetées
par l'autorité palestinienne ainsi que
les habitants des territoires occupés
qui multiplie les manifestations exemple
le 1er juillet à gaza la résistance doit
commencer dès maintenant car israël ne
reconnaîtra rien qui s'apparente au
compromis ou à la négociation
israël ne craint que la force et nous
devons nous unir pour lui résister
l'administration trump dit être en
pourparlers avec tous les pays de la
région pour finaliser un processus des
plus controversés le parquet bolivien
réclame à nouveau l'arrestation de
l'ancien président réfugié en argentine
evo morales il est accusé de délits
présumés de terrorisme et de leur
financement lors des conflits qui ont
secoué le pays en 2019
evo morales s'était proclamé vainqueur
de l'élection présidentielle où il
briguait un quatrième mandat en décembre
dernier le procureur avait déjà demandé
son arrestation pour les mêmes faits une
enquête pour fraude électorale présumée
a également été retenus contre l'ex chef
d'état en février
pour en parler nous sommes en direct de
la passe avec holly vargas reporter de
caoutchouc news c'est notre rubrique
vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous ni vargas
en direct de la passe le procureur donc
général bolivien accusé l'ancien
président morales de délits présumés de
terrorisme et de leur financement est à
nouveau demandé son arrestation de quoi
s'agit-il précisément et pourquoi autant
de détermination de la part du procureur
venus n'a de l'aude et la détention
préventive d'evo morales suite à des
accusations de terrorisme qui sont liés
à la résistance démocratique qui a après
le renversement de hotspots 2019
beaucoup de personnes dans le pays
pensent qu'il s'agit d'une tentative
d'empêcher le mouvement vers le
socialisme mas d'evo morales de
concourir lors des élections à venir et
il y à un autre une autre affaire dans
le même temps c'est le cas autour de la
fraude électorale présumée et octobre
2019 des études internationales en
pleuvait qu'il n'y avait pas eu de
fraude lors de ces élections remportées
par evo morales c'est un rapport par
exemple repris par le new york times et
le washington post
il a montré qu'il y avait des erreurs
dans les hypothèses selon lequel il y
aurait eu fraude électorale et pour
cette affaire servira également à
essayer de bannir à la participation du
mas dans les élections de septembre
le gouvernement a tout intérêt à bannir
ce mouvement car un sondage publié
aujourd'hui montre que le parti d'evo
morales à 15 points d'avancé dans les
sondages par rapport aux à la seconde
place et pourrait bien remporter les
élections
le nouveau gouvernement est donc très
sains
et redoutent que leur projet néolibéral
visant à orienter le pays vers les états
unis s'effondrerait le 6 septembre
quelles sont les chances cette fois ci
que ces poursuites aboutisse parce qu on
se souvient que la première fois c'est
interpol qui n'avait pas donné suite un
puisque evo morales n'est pas en bolivie
x justice internationale la police
internationale en tout cas de prendre le
relais quelles chances de réussite pour
le procureur le système judiciaire
libyen est sous le contrôle du nouveau
gouvernement
on s'attend donc à ce que le jugement se
fasse contre evo morales contre le mas
au niveau international c'est une autre
question
effectivement un tackle a déjà rejeté la
première tentative en janvier d'arrêter
et vous le morales
nous avons également vous en equator que
le gouvernement a essayé à trois
reprises de faire de mettre en place une
alerte rouge pour l'ex président de
gauche
et à chaque fois interpol a rejeté cette
tentative on ecuador comment poli vie il
s'agit en fait d'efforts pour mener une
persécution politique et les avocats de
morales en argentine montre qu'il s'agit
d'une preuve que la bolivie devenue un
état policier où l'état là l'état de
droit n'a plus lieu n'a plus cours et
nous espérons que les organisations
internationales s'en rendre compte
nous espérons que le monde se rend
compte qu'on prend que la bolivie
effectivement est devenue un pays
autoritariste où il n'ya plus de
démocratie
je pense qu'on va le comprendre au
niveau international aurait
effectivement le président morales l'ex
président morales a réagi sur twitter et
les firmes que cette accusation est une
preuve supplémentaire de la persécution
politique systématique du
également il rajoute la démocratie et
l'état de droit reviendront bientôt en
bolivie ça veut dire que il estime ses
chances grande de revenir au pays et
mêmes aux affaires est-ce que les
boliviens le soutiendrez selon vous le
parti le mas je ne remportera les
élections du 6 septembre
d'après les sondages les intentions de
vote sont à hauteur de 41% et la second
place n'attend que 20%
donc c'est le plus grand parti du pays
et si les élections sont libres et
justes alors le mouvement vers le
socialisme le mas les remportera et evo
morales pourra revenir au pays
la grande question c'est est-ce que les
élections pourraient avoir lieu
et si elles ont lieu seront tels
effectivement libres et équitables
le couple de gens considèrent qu'elles
n'auront pas lieu
beaucoup de ministres aux places est
telle que le ministre de l'intérieur a
retour au mourre îlots ont été très
clairs sur le fait qu'il ne pensait pas
qu'il devrait y avoir des élections en
septembre
beaucoup de groupes d'extrême droite ont
déclaré être prêts à se mobiliser contre
de telles élections et il se fonde sur
la crise du coronavirus et sur les
risques de transmission comme prétexte
pour interdire ces élections mais avec
les menaces de manifestations de
mobilisation se rend bien compte que ce
n'est pas vraiment un véritable sujet
d'inquiétude ce qui les préoccupe c'est
le risque de voir un retour de evo
morales et beaucoup de personnes au sein
du régime dont le ministre de
l'intérieur a tous mûri l'eau serait
obligé de quitter le pays ou risquer la
prison
si evo morales revenez si merci au lit
vargas d'avoir été avec nous pour notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
moscou va riposter aux mesures inamicale
je cite annoncé par londres a prévenu ce
matin le kremlin le royaume uni annonce
des sanctions à l'encontre de personnes
et organisations accusés de violations
des droits humains hier à londres a
publié une liste noire de 49 personnes
en ce sens 25 citoyens russes y figurent
et sont accusés d'être impliqués dans la
mort de l'avocat sergueï manning si lors
de sa détention
la décision prise par le gouvernement
britannique d'imposer des sanctions
contre un certain nombre d'officiels
russes en invoquant la mort de sergueï
magnitski qu'en 2009 est le reflet du
statut autoproclamé du royaume uni comme
leader mondial en matière de politique
de sanctions toutes les questions
relatives aux circonstances de la mort
de monsieur magnétique en trouver leurs
réponses il y à bien longtemps
la décision d'aujourd'hui a été de façon
évidente
conçu comme une opération de
communication et pour en parler nous
prenant la direction de moscou ont
rejoint notre correspondant antoine
clairon c'est par la voix du
porte-parole yeux kremlin que les
autorités ont réagi
dimitri peskov a pris acte de ce nouveau
train de sanctions contre la russie et
s'est réservé le droit d'y riposter
nous ne pouvons que regretter ces
mesures inamicale bien sur un principe
de réciprocité sera appliquée ainsi que
certaines réponses dans la mesure où
cela irait dans les intérêts de la
fédération de russie
l'ambassade de russie à londres a quant
à elle dénoncé ces sanctions comme je
cite une volonté de faire pression sur
des états souverains
tout en soulignant l'indépendance du
pouvoir judiciaire en russie
alors cette liste noire comprend les
noms de 49 personnes dont 25 citoyens
russes suspecté d'être impliqué dans la
mort de sergueï magnitski ce juriste
mort dans sa cellule de prison à moscou
en 2009 ces personnes ne pourront donc
pas se rendre au royaume uni et leurs
avoirs dans le pays le cas échéant
seront donc gelé parmi ces personnes
présentes sur cette liste noire il y à
des enquêteurs des juges
ou encore le président du comité
d'enquêté russe
ce n'est donc pas une bonne nouvelle
pour les relations russo britanniques
déjà plombée par la sphère skripal ou
encore par leur différend sur le dossier
ukrainien ou encore sur le dossier
syrien
et cette information qui vient tout
juste de tomber on apprend à l'instant
que les etats-unis se retirer
formellement de l'organisation mondiale
de la santé ce qu'on apprend par un
sénateur américain on sait que c'était
pas l'humeur est au beau fixe entre
donald trump et l'organisation mondiale
qui l'avait souvent critiqué avec cette
conclusion aujourd'hui donc des états
unis qui se retire formellement de l'
oms on y reviendra dans notre édition de
vingt-et-une rester avec nous donc dans
quelques instants on parlera du brésil
également le deuxième pays au monde le
plus touché avec plus d'un million de
cas de coronavirus le président bolle
sonoran a lui aussi été contrôlé positif
aujourd'hui au qu'ovide 19
et puis direction madagascar ont l'état
renforce les mesures de l'état d'urgence
[Musique]
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer tout seul dans ses
cuisines et bains je me suis aperçu que
c'était bien plus difficile qu'ils
avaient une équipe de 25 l'usiné autour
pour nous pour nos fournisseurs pour nos
équipes c'était essentiel d'ouvrir le
plus tôt possible
beaucoup des mid de la vie ne reprendra
pas de la même façon je n'adhère pas à
cette théorie du monde d'avant du monde
d'après je crois que le monde d'avant il
était formidable et qu'on a envie de le
retrouver je pensais que ça allait me
rendre plus tolérante et ben ça m'a
rendu plus affoler rang alors parfois
elle s'était d'ailleurs je voulais vous
poser justement délirer autour d'un
dessert que j'ai appelé la pêche n'a pas
le bac
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après qui serait aussi dynamique et
tonique que le monde d'avant
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
where france pour renault ce sont des
entreprises qui sont en jeu d'hier est
en fête permanente
on va pas obliger les entreprises on
proteste actuelle à garder leurs
salariés ça n'a pas de sens ça fait
longtemps que je soutiens une des
nombreuses garanties
c'est dire on propose un emploi toutes
ces personnes en attendant qu'elles
retrouvent un autre job du monde
on apporte une vision aucune et ça c'est
malheureusement dans tous les domaines
au lieu de dépenser des milliards comme
ça pour rien il faudrait mieux les
dépensés pour former les gens et les
replacer ailleurs
[Musique]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
dernier rapport du giec sur les océans
comme ça fout les jetons
on est dans une espèce de déni collectif
on ne veut pas croire ce qu'on sait les
scientifiques parlent comme anne de la
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre à
d'autres experts qui conteste naurouze
l'ordonnancé personnes non non c'est pas
vrai il ya des climats tous et non ce
n'est pas rien à part il ya des gens qui
ne sont pas des chercheurs qui parlent
que la presse met en avant parce que il
faut que du débat le gars plus de débats
aujourd'hui il ya plus aucun débat ce
changement climatique et on va vers un
vrai par une catastrophe on va vers une
vraie catastrophe et on a incapable d'en
prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas deux des six mist nous
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense qu'on est comme une guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons de vue est l'ennemi
y'en a pas d'ennemis l'ennemi c'est nous
[Musique]
la stratégie politique depuis pas mal
d'années encourage la fracture sociétale
pour éviter d'aborder les questions de
fond pour en remettre en cause la pensée
des groupes de pression pouvoir l'étude
démontre la nocivité de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine au nom de la peur de la mort
notre ministre a interdit immédiatement
son utilisation
le problème c'est que l'étude avait été
faite par des cardiologues sur la base
de données fournies par une société sacs
tissent dont certains les employés ont
des qualifications étonnant allant de
l'auteur de science-fiction à l'hôtesse
mannequin dans cette dictature de la
pensée unique
les technocrates les activistes et de
nombreux journalistes ne s'intéressent
qu'à la partie qui va dans leur sens et
censure ou dévalorise le reste on décide
de ce que le peuple doit penser
[Musique]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer en soit vous avez proposé deux
posters en falck faire que ça veut dire
facile à lire ça si la comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
quad schisme de comprendre ce qui se
passe tout l'enjeu de notre association
c'est co-construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'on a une idée d'augmentation
ou pas défini ci d'aujourd'hui en france
l'écho et les violences n'existait avant
leur confinement
et pendant ce confinement c'est vrai
qu'il ya sept ce cadre lecture les taux
de féminicide a plus que j'étais pas
doublé mais bien monté forcément on n'a
pas encore tous les chiffres officiels
c'est très difficile
bourreau n'est jamais n'est jamais loin
finalement c'est le confinement dans le
confinement
cela veut dire qu'il ya un huit clos au
sein des foyers
et forcément dans les femmes victimes de
violences de nombreux repas à 3
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission
il est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mardi 7 juillet jaillir verso narrow
testé positif aux coronavirus le
président brésilien s'est soumis à un
test suite à la présence de symptômes
il dit recevoir un traitement
l'hydroxyde chloroquine et elle est
parfaitement bien
l'om est lui souhaite un rapide
rétablissement le brésil qui est loin
d'en avoir terminé avec locaux vides 19
le pays enregistre plus de vingt mille
nouveaux cas ces dernières 24 à
madagascar la capitale antananarivo est
de nouveau placé en confinement en
raison d'un regain de la propagation du
coronavirus 4000 militaires ont été
beaux déployés dans les rues pour faire
respecter les consignes durant une durée
durant une quinzaine de jours en
quelques jours la barre des 3000
personnes infectées a été franchie en
compte 33 morts et 45 patients en
réanimation en france emmanuel macron a
fixé quatre grands axes de travail dont
la reconstruction du pays et le
patriotisme républicain au gouvernement
qu'il a réuni pour la première fois
aujourd'hui lors du conseil des
ministres le nouveau ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin a vécu une
première journée mouvementée avec
plusieurs manifestations de militantes
féministes qui appelle à sa démission en
raison d'accusations de viol à son
encontre
[Musique]
on vient de l'apprendre c'est officiel
les etats-unis se retire de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
ce après avoir suspendu leurs fonds il
ya plusieurs semaines déjà c'est ce que
l'administration un trust vient
d'annoncer au congrès américain sans
aucune autre précision pour le moment et
le président gère ball sonar au testé
positif aux coronavirus aujourd'hui lui
qui a pourtant toujours minimisé la
pandémie au début de la semaine il a
même opposé son veto à des articles sur
la loi sur l'utilisation de masques dans
les lieux publics
il a finalement été contrainte de se
faire tester suite à des symptômes
le brésil est le deuxième pays au monde
le plus touché valentin cars entiers
avec emilie google jaillir bol sonar ou
contaminés par le coït 19
le président brésilien de 65 ans l'a
annoncé lors d'un entretien accordé à
plusieurs chaînes de télévision
moi par exemple si je n'avais pas fait
le test et bien je ne connaîtrai pas le
résultat
et il s'est avéré positif le chef d'état
avait longtemps minimisé la maladie mais
il avait fini par prendre quelques
précautions à la suite de symptômes dus
coronavirus chose rare il s'était même
montré avec un masque sur le visage
avant d'effectuer un test de dépistage
du coc vide 19 quelques heures avant
cette intervention gerben senard a
opposé son veto à deux articles de la
loi sur l'utilisation des masques dans
les lieux publics
un assouplissement qui a lieu en même
temps que la réouverture des bars
restaurants et salons de beauté à sao
paulo capitale économique du pays dans
une nouvelle étape de déconfinement la
ville sort d'une quarantaine qui a duré
une centaine de jours les commerces
pourront ouvrir quotidiennement durant
six heures seulement à 40 % de leur
capacité d'accueil des réouvertures cinq
jours après celle de rio de janeiro qui
enchante commerçants et clients
je meurs vraiment envie de sortir ça
vous donne un sentiment de liberté vous
savez être à la maison pendant trois
mois sans sortir pour quoi que ce soit
et difficile
la plupart des clients travaillent à
domicile la plupart d'entre eux
travaillent encore à domicile et en
raison des horaires réduits
ce n'est pas bon pour nous non plus car
on s'occupe des clients la nuit on
travaillait de 9 à 7 heures avant et
maintenant nous sommes ici de 11 à 4
heures donc c'est un peu difficile
si le pays se dé confine la pandémie est
toujours présente en termes de
contamination et de décès le brésil est
toujours le deuxième pays le plus touché
au monde derrière les états unis et pour
en parler nous sommes avec hervé théry
docteur en géographie professeur à
l'université de sao paulo bonsoir hervé
théry merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france avant le président
président un brésilien et un bol sonar
au positif au corona virus et c'est le
comble pour l'un des dirigeants les plus
au corona sceptique sur la planète
non je crois pas je crois qu'il a
vraiment fait tout pour l'avoir refusé
d'appliquer les consignes il s'est réuni
avec des tas de gens au plus près il
avait fait tout ce qu'il fallait pas et
il a prouvé par l'absurde que les
consignes étaient bonnes alors oui enfin
il à prouver par l'absurde
effectivement mais enfin il a toujours
minimisé la pandémie il a toujours voilà
traîné des pieds pour faire appliquer
les le confinement c'est quand même
assez cocasse ce qui se passe au brésil
aujourd'hui on se souvient aussi boris
johnson qui était un petit peu dans dans
le même temps et qui a aussi eu lé le
coronavirus que faut-il finalement
retenir comme le sont pour ses
dirigeants
boris jeunes eux seuls une fois qu'il
l'a attrapée est allé à l'hôpital il
s'est fait soigner il a rendu hommage
aux soignants pour ball son héros ça
prend pas ce chemin là la première chose
qu'il a faite en annonçant qu'ils
étaient atteints s'est retiré son masque
pour parler aux journalistes de plus
près et il a dit non non j'ai eu 38
degrés et 38 degrés de fièvre j'ai pris
l'hydro koroki du tout va bien donc ils
vont pas du tout le chemin du repenti un
simple outil alors effectivement il dit
recevoir un traitement à l'hydroxyethyl
au rock indie allait parfaitement bien
on rappelle que ce traitement était
extrêmement critique et d'ailleurs voilà
rejeter entre guillemets par par l' oms
comme un traitement valable que doit-on
effectivement retenir aussi de cette
séquence n'est pas rien quand un
dirigeant influent de se soigner avec
une molécule et qu'il dit allait
parfaitement bien c'est une forme de
voile à de provocation par rapport à l'
oms notamment de défis il est vraiment
dans le délit est dans le défi fait
partie des six pays au monde qui sont
dans le déni il ya trois pays et le
burundi le brésil et la biélorussie le
nicaragua et j'en oublie deux autres n'y
a que six pays au monde qui font ça et
il est il est dedans et donc il est un
délit n'a aussi appelé ça le club des
autruches
c'est à dire expliquez-nous ça veut dire
quoi à ton mini miss
on y croit vraiment bas on fait semblant
pas y croire fais comme les autruches ce
conte ce qu'ont dit les autruches en
tout cas s'il ya qu'elle enfonce d'eau
peut-être dans le sable en espérant et
de protéger il a cédé ce qu'est vraiment
le refus de prendre en compte la coudre
réalité et vous avez raison ce serait
cocasse c'est cocasse où ce serait
cocasse il n'y avait pas plusieurs
dezier dizaines de milliers de morts à
la clé il ya vraiment beaucoup de gens
qui va en mourir
de fait que ont tiré à hue et à dia le
gouvernement fédéral sous sa direction
ni il a déjà joué deux fois son
ministère de la santé alors que les
gouverneurs des états et les gouverneurs
de ville essaie de faire respecter le
confinement donc oui dans un pays comme
la france où c'est à peu près
coordonnées il ya quand même des
cafouillages imaginer que les présidents
des régions les présidents département
et le ministère de la santé dit des
choses différentes à la population
serait complètement perdu alors on voit
au moment vous nous parler ces images
effectivement de funérailles
d'enterrement au brésil ces enterrements
entre guillemets de masse
mille nouveaux cas en 24 heures on a du
mal quand même à penser que que les
brésiliens ne se révolte pas devant un
président qui continue est dans un déni
que vous voulez nous décrire et les
morts qui qui continuent d'affluer
tous les jours quelle est la réaction
des brésiliens la majorité dans tous les
sondages disent qu'ils sont aussi bons
convaincu qu'il faut rester confiné ce
qu'on entend le plus c'est la minorité
de 25 5% des partisans inconditionnels
de bots you know qui font du bruit des
manifestations mais dans mes collègues
dans mes amis dans ma belle famille les
gens restent confinés ils sont pas fous
et donc ce qu'on voit le plus c'est le
sait là les gens qui défient et puis
d'autre part les gens pauvres qui n'ont
pas le choix qui doivent sortir tous les
jours pour gagner de quoi se nourrir et
nourrir leurs enfants et donc ne pas
verser dans pas appliquer le confinement
donc tous les gens qui sont dans la rue
sont pas là par des fils y en a qui sont
là par des filles aujourd'hui l'om est
ce pas revancharde finalement souhaite
un rapide rétablissement à bôle sonar ou
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
voilà enfin sont faits de la fiction ici
peut-être mais si sa maladie s'aggraver
il pourrait peut-être retrouver la voix
de la raison et changer sa vision
justement sur la maladie et surtout sur
sa gestion de la crise a jugé par ses
premières réactions pas tellement que je
lisais attendant un éditorial du
principal journal brésilien qui
s'appelle la follia feuilles de saint
paul est un des chroniqueurs disait ce
que le président aurait lui à faire pour
de l'aisance et de mourir du coc vide je
serai le vivement qu'il meure et quand
on en est là c'est vraiment qu'il est
très forte radicalisation
oui effectivement sao paulo où vous êtes
est en train de se décomposer c'est bien
ça ça veut dire qu'il ya quand même des
régions du brésil où où la situation
s'améliore qu'au fond c'est mon nom
c'est enfin apparemment elles sont paul
le pic est en train de passer mais le
virus se répand vers l'intérieur donc
des régions qui étaient jusque là
protégé sont atteintes mais sans paul il
ya donc 20 millions d'habitants dont
quatre millions et demi dans les régions
les plus pauvres de la zone s et ont pas
le choix qu'ils ont jamais respecté le
confinement merci à hervé théry docteur
en géographie professeur à l'université
de sao paulo d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france la capitale de
madagascar à nouveau placé en
confinement en raison d'un regain de la
propagation du coronavirus le
gouvernement décide de limiter les
poches épidémique à antananarive et sa
banlieue nord pendant le week-end 4000
militaires ont été déployés dans les
rues de la capitale malgache pour faire
respecter les consignes durant une
quinzaine de jours
les derniers chiffres sont inquiétants
en quelques jours la barre des 3000
personnes infectées a été franchie on
compte 33 morts et 45 patients en
réanimation
je suis vendeuse de sacs en plastique
on nous chasse et nous ne pouvons pas
vendre alors que l'argent ne tombe pas
du ciel
j'ai déjà vendu mais marc huit mondes
rats je n'ai plus rien à manger rien
lavande ou va-t-on aller
vous savez les petits gens souffrent ils
sont tout le temps confinés
je propose qu'on leur donne la
possibilité de travailler pour gagner de
l'argent
cela soulagerait un peu mais là le seul
moyen qu'on trouve c'est de les menacer
laissez les gens vendre parce qu'ils
sont en difficulté
moi je suis une veuve et je suis sans
ressources les responsables sociaux
doivent regarder de près notre cas parce
que les gens sont confinés mais il y en
a qui doivent sortir pour des raisons de
santé de décès ou des obligations pour
nous ou nos enfants mais pour nous
apporter un témoignage de la situation
sur place à madagascar on retrouve un
air du temps de madagascar tarik mallard
bonsoir paris caval'art merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
madagascar il ya eu confinement pluie
déconfinement et l'art confinement on
imagine que c'est compliqué dans quel
état d'esprit et la population alors
bonsoir à tous oui effectivement on a eu
un soulier confinement à la fin du mois
du mois de mars qui n'a pas été très
efficace parce qu'il y avait très peu de
casse bonbons la méga star et lundi la
population était confiné donc les gens
sont malheureusement l'économie est
assez informelle et donc ils sont
obligés de travailler pour se nourrir on
ne peut pas dire qu'il ya encore de
tension mais on peut craindre que ça
arrive c'est les mesures sont l'air
assez strictes puisque il ya 4000
militaires qui ont été déployés dans la
capitale et les villes voisines pour
contre harnes justement les malgaches à
ne plus circuler comment ça se passe sur
place il y à des amendes effectivement
on peut vraiment plus sortir son peine
d'être arrêté par des militaires alors à
partir de 14h parce qu'il ya un
couvre-feu qui met en place à partir de
14h dans la ville juste pour tananarive
les autres discrit songe à l'aide d'une
façon différente
je sais pas si pas fait l'expérience je
ne connais personne qui l'ont fait
qu'ils soient pas arrêtés par des
militaires
mais effectivement il est interdit de
circuler et il n'y a personne dans les
rues sauf pour ce qui concerne les
véhicules de ravitaillement des magasins
de preuves de produits de première
nécessité sur place est ce qu'on arrive
à expliquer pourquoi justement
les choses se sont aggravées à nouveau
puisqu'il ya eu un confinement comme en
france qui a une bon résultat est ce
qu'il ya eu un relâchement les malgaches
n'ont pas pris peut-être la mesure de la
gravité n'ont pas respecté les gestes
bavière barrière en tout cas comment
peut-on l'expliquer alors je pense que
j'ai activement les malgaches ont connu
un certain relâchement un moment dans la
crise les dirigeants du pays n'ont pas
forcément été plus clair possible sur la
dangerosité de la situation et puis
encore une fois c'est une économie
informelle
la plupart des habitants du pays n'ont
pas le choix que de travailler pour se
nourrir et au jour le jour
donc au bout d'un moment ils sont
obligés de sortir de leur maison et de
se mêler à la foule s est même très haut
vol que oui est-ce que pardonnez moi est
ce que justement ils ont dès mars qu'il
ya des mesures de protection qui sont
organisées peut-être voilà dans
certaines entreprises vous dites les
gens sont obligés d'aller travailler
certes mais on sait ce qu'ils sont
protégés au moins alors dans la capitale
on peut voir que les gens portent les
masques respectent les mesures barrières
dès qu'on s'éloigne un petit peu on voit
que c'est moins le cas
mais sur place il dans les entreprises
locales ou les gens sont obligés de
travailler il y a des il ya des règles
qui sont mises en place pour que les
malgaches respectent les mesures
barrières alors on imagine vous l'avez
bien c'est une économie qui est parfois
voilà compliqué vous même vous aviez
trouvé un travail pendant le
déconfinement hélas plus rien on imagine
que c'est la situation de beaucoup de
malgaches et que ça peut être
extrêmement compliqué est ce qu'il ya au
moins des aides d'état sur place comme
il ya eu en france on ça n'existe pas
alors oui ça peut être assez compliqué
ensuite les aides d'état sont sains sont
allouées aux familles et aux gens qui
sont vraiment vraiment besoin
mais on peut pas dire que les choses
soient claires et que l'on sache
vraiment qui a accès ou pas et qu'elle
sur les conditions pour y avoir accès en
tout cas dans le secteur privé
l'état n'intervient que très très peu
merci beaucoup tarifs mais l'art en tout
cas nous avoir apporté votre témoignage
e puis à madagascar où je le rappelle
donc on reconfirme la population après
un regard de coronavirus merci à vous
est toujours en afrique
une des conséquences du coronavirus le
paludisme en côte d'ivoire les
populations craignent de se rendre à
l'hôpital et de contracter covit 19
les personnes atteintes de paludisme ne
se soigne donc pas le point avec marc
cacouault ghislain menzah et cyrielle
bruit la lutte contre le paludisme mise
à mal par le coronavirus à abidjan au
centre hospitalier de la commune d'abobo
jours de visite médicale pour david
le jeune homme de 28 ans souffre depuis
quelques jours de symptômes qu'il
connaît bien ceux du paludisme
mon coach m'avait pourtant le jeune
homme a longtemps hésité avant de se
présenter au centre dans son entourage
une rumeur persiste selon laquelle un
test du coc vie 19 est obligatoire
lorsque l'on se rend à l'hôpital selon
la population de ce quartier populaire
effectuer un dépistage augmentent les
risques de contracter le virus
pour éviter d'avoir à le faire les
ivoiriens préfèrent s'automédicamenter
face à cette pratique les médecins
tirent la sonnette d'alarmé
c'est un peu de communes donc je vais
faire un peu de se mettre pour gorée le
problème voilà donc on les met encore je
me souviens - une automédication qui met
en péril le suivi du paludisme dans le
pays
beaucoup de patients consommerait des
antipaludéens persuadé qu'il les protège
du coc vite 19 à l'institut pasteur du
quartier de cocody
une étude sur l'impact du coronavirus
sur le paludisme a été lancé en avril
dernier son objectif démontrer que la
surconsommation d'antipaludéens peut
entraîner des résistances face au
traitement et ainsi rendre les patients
plus vulnérables
cette prévention n'existe pas ils ne se
connaissent pas mais au contraire il
atteint défavorisés aux parasites à
développer d essence aux médicaments et
des mets ce médicament sera pas efficace
et donc déjà quand votre lettre et hervé
ses médicaments ça n'a pas marché
conséquence le taux de mortalité le taux
de mobilité de la maladie va augmenter
donc la côte cela qu'on cesse ici in
vitro ce pouvoir si le médicament marche
ou pas que le parasite ou pas cette
étude s'achèvera en avril 2021
pour l'heure le taux de mortalité liée
au paludisme serait en augmentation de
15% par rapport à l'année dernière
en 2020 le paludisme risque de faire
près de quatre cent mille morts
supplémentaires selon l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
l'australie sera confiné également les
autorités du pays annonce un retour du
confinement à melbourne un plus de cinq
millions de personnes ont reçu l'ordre
ce mardi de rester chez eux pour une
durée d'au moins six semaines
191 nouveaux cas ont été détectés en 24
heures ce qui rend difficile le traçage
des personnes infectées
les élèves suivront à nouveau un
enseignement à distance tandis que les
restaurants et les cafés ne pourront
plus servir que des plats à emporter l
état de victoria a fermé ses frontières
l'isolant du reste du pays
ces chiffres de nouveaux cas d'infection
sont particulièrement ingérable et il
est simplement impossible avec de tels
taux d'infection que les personnels qui
sont au contact et les ressources
physiques nécessaires
peu importe d'où ils viennent et quel
équipement elle porte pour continuer à
lutter contre le virus et à le contenir
sans que des décisions significatives
soient prises si nous devions échoué
dans l'adoption de telles mesures alors
nous n'aurons pas 200 nouveaux cas par
jour mais bien plus et cela deviendrait
vite une spirale totalement de contrôler
l épreuve émergent quant à la
transmission du kobe 19 dans l'air c'est
en tout cas ce qu'a déclaré l oms après
qu'un groupe de 239 scientifique et
publié a publié le résultat d'études
dans la revue clinical infectious
disease d'oxford est longtemps accusé de
nier l'accumulation de preuves
concernant une possible transmission du
virus dans l'air c'est le directeur
général de l'om est-ce qu'ils allaient
s'est exprimé en conférence de presse à
ce sujet il a fallu douze semaines pour
que le monde atteignent 400 mille cas de
co vide au cours du week end
plus de 400 mille cas ont été recensés
dans le monde entier
il y a maintenant eu 11,4 millions de
cas de kovy de 10,9 et plus de cinq cent
trente cinq mille vies ont été perdues
l'épidémie s'accélère et il est clair
que nous n'avons pas atteint le pic de
la pandémie
l'épidémie qui s'accélère donc toujours
selon l oms le pic ne serait pas encore
atteint les états unis restent le pays
le plus touché suivi du brésil et de
l'inde l'iran annonce de son côté un
triste record avec 200 morts en 24
heures la situation se stabilise
timidement en europe le point en images
oh
[Musique]
où
je
[Musique]
on
je
à
[Musique]
on
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons du remaniement et de la
prise de fonction de gérald darmanin
notamment au poste de ministre de
l'intérieur qui fait polémique
et puis nous évoquerons le ségur de la
santé de l'enquète judiciaires lancées
par la cour de justice de la république
à l'encontre d'edouard philippe olivier
ferrand et agnès buzyn pour la gestion
de la crise du coc vie de 19
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
le fait que nous avons eu ce problème de
la pandémie qui a été mondiale va amener
d'autres façons de faire des affaires et
les choses vont beaucoup se concentrer
sur l'humain et sur l'environnement
partout en afrique les présidents
prennent conscience qu'il faut vraiment
se réindustrialiser et là je pense que
l'aco vie va permettre à cette ré
industrialisation cela ne veut pas dire
qu'on ne doit plus commercer mais
commercer de manière différents qui
permettent à tout un chacun d'avoir un
travail de dessin un salaire décent
je pense que le salaire qui permet de
vivre ça c'est le plus important
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes philosophe de formation mais
philosophe aussi de profession est ce
qui explique cette énergie que vous
mettez cet engagement critiques contre
le féminisme actuelle je pense que un
modèle de société est à bout de souffle
et que nous avons en effet besoin de
repenser le fondement anthropologique et
philosophique du monde dans lequel nous
vivons
quels rapports où nous devons instaurer
aux êtres et aux choses
on s'oriente vers une société très
puritaine oui puritaine au sens où le
désir et et criminaliser le fait que
l'homme soit sensible aux charmes
féminins et rendu suspect
[Musique]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer au soir vous avez proposé deux
posters en falck fall que ça veut dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
pour construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
21h30 heure française merci nous
rejoindre en direct sur rt france
premier conseil des ministres cet après
midi pour le gouvernement castex après
les passations de pouvoir ce matin place
à l'action avec huit nouveaux ministres
entrants ont fait le point avec estelle
farges
après les nominations hier place aux
travaux pratiques aujourd'hui avec le
tout premier pas conseil des ministres
du gouvernement castex la nouvelle
équipe composée de seize ministres de 14
ministres est délégué et d'un secrétaire
d'état s'est réunie à cet après midi
autour d' emmanuel macron pendant 1h45
le couple exécutif
macron à castex qui souhaite accélérer
la cadence et montrer que l'équipe est
opérationnel à l'issue du conseil
elle s'est tenu le traditionnel compte
rendu tenue pour la première fois par à
gabriel attal porte parole du
gouvernement à qui a évoqué une équipe
de combat et d'un rassemblement avec un
nouveau chemin à qui s'articule autour
de quatre grands axes la reconstruction
du pays
d'abord reconstruction économique social
environnemental et territorial et
culturel puis le patriotisme républicain
je vous propose d'écouter à ce propos
gabriela talent le deuxième axe de ce
nouveau chemin c'est le patriotisme
républicain par la public a parfois trop
manqué à manquer à ses propres promesses
et donc nous allons avancer avec des
objectifs clairs aller au bout de notre
ambition sur l'école qui a démarré je le
disais avec le dédoublement des classes
porté par jean michel bancaire il nous
faut poursuivre dans ce mouvement
c'est un défi historique pour notre
jeunesse qui a vécu un moment
extrêmement difficile avec le
confinement et sur laquelle nous devons
continuer à investir et des annonces
seront faites autour de ce sujet pour
l'avenir de notre jeunesse
le porte parole du gouvernement à qui a
aussi évoqué la volonté du chef de
l'état d'avoir une politique plus ali
il est ainsi qu une politique européenne
forte noter enfin que jean castex
réunira ses ministres dans un séminaire
gouvernemental samedi matin au sein de
ce gouvernement certaines nominations
suscite des polémiques car trois
ministres sont concernés à différents
degrés par des enquêtes judiciaires les
explications en images
[Musique]
non
il
[Musique]
et
et parmi donc s'est mis sous le coup
d'une enquête gérald darmanin donc on
vient de voir qui fait l'objet d'une
plainte pour viol entourage du président
on n'y voit pas un obstacle à sa
promotion la sphère avait déjà bénéficié
d'un non lieu en 2018
mais la cour d'appel de paris a ordonné
la reprise des investigations il ya bien
évidemment la présomption d'innocence
mais sur les réseaux plusieurs
responsables associatifs ou membres de
l'opposition dénonce l'envoi d'un signal
désastreux
jadis quand on était visé par une
enquête
il arrivait qu'on démissionne là il
s'agit d'une enquête pour viol et
darmanin et promu quel signal désastreux
non seulement ce nouveau gouvernement
n'ouvre rien de nouveau sur le front de
l'écologie mais surtout il met même à la
tête de la police un homme visé par une
enquête pour viol harcèlement sexuel et
abus de confiance
quel affront pour la grande cause du
quinquennat darmanin à l'intérieur
dupond moretti à la justice je la sens
moyen la grande cause du quinquennat
vrai gérald darmanin jusqu'ici ministre
de l'action et des comptes publics prend
donc la tête du ministère de l'intérieur
il succède au très critiqué christophe
castaner pour en parler nous sommes avec
alexandre langrois secrétaire général du
syndicat policier vigie bonsoir avec son
emploi merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france on vous a souvent
entendu ici est très critique vis-à-vis
de l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur on
imagine tout d'abord que que le départ
de christophe castaner a été une
satisfaction pour vous et vos collègues
c'est une satisfaction si jamais hanche
on change l'équipe pour avoir une
nouvelle direction à prendre
et malheureusement le premier siècle de
monsieur darmana a été dû dire je loue
le bilan de mon prédécesseur donc a
priori on a changé les personnes on va
pas changer le contenu
donc c'est ça ou ça pose un sérieux
problème malgré la réjouissance du
départ de monsieur castaner alors ça
c'est effectivement peut-être on peut
laisser le bénéfice du doute pour pour
les politesses de passation de pouvoir
gérald darmanin réservé aujourd'hui son
premier déplacement en province
en lot-et-garonne afin de rendre hommage
à la jeune gendarme tué samedi soir par
un conducteur qui voulait éviter un
contrôle routier
c'est pas un bon signal ça pour vous
comment les nous avons des ministres
qu'il déplace par contre nous n'avons
pas forcément les moyens d'effectuer nos
missions en sécurité donc on aurait
préféré des moyens plus qu'aucun
déplacement ministériel
il s'est également déplacée aux mureaux
saluer la mémoire de nos collègues qui
ont été tuées par des terroristes chez
eux
effectivement c'est un beau geste
également mais pour autant nous ne
sommes pas plus en sécurité aujourd'hui
et qu'avant et enfin on passe sous
silence la première cause de mort
violente des policiers c'est le suicide
mais ce castanet répartie avec 84 de nos
collègues qui sont sont suicidés plus de
140 de nos collègues se sont suicidés
depuis le début du quinquennat et sa pas
un mot et pourtant ça aurait été une
prise de conscience parce que ça sa
relative cette enveloppe tous les
problèmes qu'il ya dans la police
nationale c'est un malaise général de
manque de moyens de sens du métier et
donc là on aurait pu parler de choses
sérieuses et malheureusement nous sommes
sur des déplacements de la communication
est toujours pas des actes alors c'est
vrai qu'il vient de prendre ses
fonctions gérald darmanin on le rappelle
gérald darmanin le sarkozyste nicolas
sarkozy qui n'était pas connu pour être
le moins proche des policiers ça ça ne
vous donne pas un petit peu d'espoir
quand même qui est un changement de
mentalité en votre faveur
alors ça dépend ce qu'on attend d'un
ministre monsieur k sarkozy avait eu un
très bon départ était très apprécié au
début puis après les mis en place la
politique du chiffre
politique du chiffre qui a détruit notre
métier donc malheureusement monsieur
sarkozy ne laisse pas a laissé beaucoup
d'espoir au début de son à son arrivée
et finalement quand il est parti il
était honni de la plupart des policiers
est encore aujourd'hui on paye la
politique du chiffre et la casse sociale
que ça engendre la perte de sens de
notre métier
donc non effectivement ce n'est pas un
signal très positif que ce soit un
proche de monsieur sarkozy
et la deuxième chose qui a été rappelé
dans le reportage également si plus
besoin de quelqu'un d'exemplaire à la
tête de ce ministère
monsieur castaner était un ancien
qu'avec des contacts du grand banditisme
du sud de la france et monsieur darmana
est sous le coup d'une procédure pour
viol donc ça pose un problème
effectivement parce que qu'il soit
innocent ou coupable
on va suspects et les suites de
l'enquêté ce que ça pourrait donner
ensuite nous avons une surcharge de
travail
déjà rien qu'aujourd'hui nous avons des
féministes qui sont venus au ministère
pour manifester contre sa dominer
on les policiers ont déjà assez de
travail comme ça sans avoir en rajouter
également ne seront pas dans le soupçon
avérée de monsieur castetner donc la
présomption d'innocence il aurait été
peut-être judicieux d'attendre la fin de
la procédure
d'autant que sous le mandat tueur de
monsieur castanet à une hausse des
agressions sexuelles dans la police et
que le ministre n'avait rien fait avait
même laissé faire et avait poursuivi les
lanceurs des lettres de ces agressions
sexuelles que depuis les hauteurs a été
condamné par la justice donc peut-être
que le message de m quelqu'un qui est ce
type de procédure est poursuivi par la
justice c'est pas le signal qu'attendait
non plus les policiers
alors y avait plusieurs n'ont évidemment
quitter circulaient comme on m'a souvent
dans ce genre de situation est ce que
yat il un nom aujourd'hui vous avez
envie de nous dévoiler que vous auriez
aimé voir justement la place de gérald
darmanin qui aurait pour vous était un
bon signal envers les forces de l'ordre
y aurait eu sans doute plusieurs noms
n'avaient pas on avait des noms
qu'éventuellement mais qu'on gardera
pour pas leur faire de l'ombre où les
leur porter tort car on n'a pas consulté
personne pour donner c'est non par
contre la chaux ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'il y avait plein de candidats
possibles qu aurait pu même des proches
de la majorité présidentielle mais pas
une personne avec des possibles on avait
plutôt un profil type pas de procédure
exemplarité et qui veut prendre soin des
policiers pour que les policiers
puissent assurer leurs missions en tout
en toute quiétude
et là on nous envoie quelqu'un qui était
avant au budget aux comptes publics
alors que nos heures supplémentaires ont
été payées au rabais
donc c'est dire que nos heures
supplémentaires qui ont explosé pendant
le quinquennat et plus particulièrement
sous le mandat de monsieur castetner
monsieur castaner nozeran fin payer en
partie l'année dernière mais moins chers
que leur normale ce qui veut dire que
l'année prochaine nous aurons des heures
supplémentaires qui sont budgétés parce
que ça coûte moins cher de co2 d'épuiser
les policiers plutôt que des blés les
épaules et avec des renforts donc
effectivement mettre quelqu'un qui était
derrière à la main d'oeuvre au paiement
n'est pas non plus forcément un bon
signe
vous n'avez pas évoquer la jeunesse de
gérald darmanin c'est pourtant parfois
un reproche qu'on a bien fait en tout
cas la jeunesse mais en tout cas le fait
de pas nécessairement avoir les épaules
pour prendre ce ministère qui est
difficile
on l'a vu ces dernières semaines qu'ils
étaient à chaque fois 2
sur le devant de la scène la crise des
gilet jaune
les manifestations anti violence
présumée policière pour vous il peut
avoir quand même les épaules il peut
surprendre de ce point de vue là alors
la jeunesse n'est pas un critère de pour
au conseil la jeunesse même peut être un
atout parce qu'il est peut-être plus
connectés avec la population actuelle
avec les nouvelles technologies avec une
police donnant maintenant il peut
surprendre s'il surprend c'est que
justement il sera taillé pour le costume
est pour le moment nous n'avons pas eu
de grand ministre de l'intérieur depuis
des années les policiers quand ils
parlent de dernier gopro ministre de
l'intérieur il parle de charles pasqua
et de pierre joxe qui commencent à
s'adapter
c'était les années 80 et donc c'est donc
bien également que ce n'est pas une
couleur politique qu'attendent les
policiers c'est quelqu'un qui s'occupe
de la maison police qui s'occupe de
faire le ménage aussi des brebis
galeuses pour qu'on puisse travailler en
conscience c'est à voir
l'exemplarité que quand nous arrêtons
des gens puissent pas dû dire mais vous
avez vu ce que vos photos les riches et
vous vous avez vu ce que le ministre
fait vous avez vu voilà on voudrait
juste pour travailler sereinement dix
ans la loi c'est ça et c'est la même
pour tout le monde
il recevra d'ici jeudi les organisations
syndicales clairement quels vont être
vos attentes on imagine que ça va être
une réunion musclé et plein de
revendications alors déjà les
organisations syndicales ne pas parler
soit tout comme l'habitude du ministère
depuis que c'est monsieur macro
commandes donc évidemment il va recevoir
les organismes syndicats qui ont été
dites représentatives aux dernières
élections
nous rappelons qu'à une procédure pour
fraude électorale de ces élections il va
sans doute également recevoir le fsi
cfdt qui rame où rappelons le son
secrétaire général pour bons et loyaux
services
bien qu'il soit minoritaire et nous
représentative dans la police nationale
a pu partir à tahiti avec sa femme avec
un poste créé exactement pour ça va d'un
poste fictif
donc en fait il va y avoir que les
copains la bande d'amis qui va se
retrouver et moi je mets un billet que
les policiers vont rentrer chez eux bien
sagement parce que les syndicats
représentatifs ou minoritaires qui vont
être reçus vont passer un message en
disant rentrez chez vous tout va bien
les sens ça chance à ce ministre alors
que justement c'est parce qu'on attend a
par contre il ya une dizaine
d'organisations qui ne sont pas
représentatives etc ont été victimes de
la fraude électorale aux dernières
élections qui ne seront pas reçus et
c'est bien malheureux
merci beaucoup alexandre langlois
d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france pour
réagir donc à cette nomination de gérald
darmanin au ministère de l'intérieur
merci à vous la cour de justice de la
république ouvre aujourd'hui une enquête
judiciaire sur la gestion ministérielle
pendant la crise sanitaire
l'ancien chef du gouvernement edouard
philippe l'ex-ministre de la santé agnès
buzyn et son successeur olivier verront
devons répondre aux questions de la
commission d'instruction
en pause notamment la pénurie de masques
les anciens ministres sont visés par de
nombreuses plaintes pour mise en danger
de la vie d'autrui et homicide
involontaire et puis les discussions
aussi concernant les négociations sur
les salaires des personnels hospitaliers
ont repris en fin de journée jean castex
annonce sur ce point sur twitter une
hausse de 20,1 milliards d'euros ce soir
pour les salaires des soignants elle ce
qui porte l'enveloppé totale à 7,5
milliards pour leur rémunération et
syndicats ont souhaité 8 milliards pour
rappel une chose est certaine le nouveau
premier ministre veut conclure les
négociations du ségur de la santé cette
semaine
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec frédéric et à blizzard économiste
de la santé
auteur de et alors la réforme globale de
la santé c'est pour quand aux éditions
fauves grand prix on le précise du
meilleur livre de l'économie de l'année
2020 à ses côtés fabrice di vizio
avocats des professions de santé plus
particulièrement du collectif c 19 à
l'origine de plusieurs plaintes bonsoir
à tous les deux merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors conclure
les négociations du ségur cette semaine
est ce que cela vous semble possible
frédéric blizzard est tout tout est
possible maintenant d'abord il ya un
diagnostic est assez partagée c'est que
la crise de l'hôpital public est une
crise du système de santé et n'est pas
réductible à un problème de rémunération
donc même si dans le dans le meilleur
des scénarios on arrive à conclure un
accord ce qui joue ce qui évidemment est
possible à partir du moment où vous êtes
capable de mettre des milliards
quasiment sans limites et surtout
des milliards qui ne sont pas financés
puisque les c'était 6 milliards c'est 7
milliards 3 maintenant et on sait
toujours pas comment est-ce qu'on va les
financer puisque la sécurité sociale
c'est pas l'état cyclos de sel peut pas
s'endetter indéfiniment c'est pas c'est
pas de l'investissement sont des charges
courantes que vous amenez donc il faut
que les français sachent s'ils savaient
peut-être de la csg en plus si les
charges sociales en plus mais forcément
il y aura 7 milliards 300 millions ce
soir de charges supplémentaires à
financer par les charges sociales ou la
csg de jeu donc va peut-être qu'on peut
trouver un accord si on n'a pas de
limites d'antan dans la hausse des
charges
mais encore une fois ça ne réglera rien
au problème de l'hôpital public qui qui
qui a un choc dit notre activité depuis
des années bon du fait d'un certain
nombre de réformes qui ont été faites
peut-être qu'on y reviendra donc
donc si c'est une si c'est un accord
dans la semaine comme le veut le premier
ministre de toute façon ça ne peut être
qu'un accord de cours de courte durée
fabrice di vizio on va surtout parler
avec vous des fameuses plainte mais je
vouvoyais elle a opiné de la tête c'est
vrai que vous connaissez aussi ces
dossiers puisque vous les connaissez vin
bien ces soignants vous représentez il
ya eu cette annonce effectivement ce
soir de jean castex qui veut conclure
rapidement les choses et annonce donc
mettre 7 milliards d'euros sur la table
alors que les syndicats en veulent lui
tond se rapproche surtout même de ce que
souhaitent les soignants à ce qu'il ya
une chance pour vous justement que ça
aboutisse et que cela satisfasse ces
soignants justement ce soir voyez vous
je crois qu'on est mal très français
c'est qu'on pense qu'on alignant des
milliards ont réglé des problèmes
le problème c'est que souvent on avignon
des milliards de manière j'ai envie de
dire complètement inconditionnel des
manières comme ça finalement sur la
table eh ben on ajoute des problèmes je
dis pas qu'à pas un problème de
rémunération à l'hôpital jeudi que
limiter le problème de l'hôpital à la
rémunération c'est extrêmement réducteur
et qu'on aurait pu attendre de ces
secteurs de la santé qu'ils se
saisissent vraiment du problème j'avais
dix ans
au départ rien n'aboutit pas de ségur et
à la sortie du ségur je consulte
partager cet avis non pas que
des rations le tout sur la duration ne
soit pas un problème mais d'abord du
financement effectivement mais deux on
est passé à côté des vrais problèmes
on est passé à côté de quel hôpital on
veut on est passé à côté de quelques
opérations entre la ville et l'hôpital
on est passé à côté des vrais enjeux
stratégiques de santé qu'on vous révéler
ce qu'au guidon se copie n'était pas
seulement un problème de rémunération de
l'hôpital il était bien autre chose tout
autre chose en fait le problème c'est
que comme on a un enjeu de communication
est un enjeu politique encore il fallait
faire les choses vite et est allé donc
les faire mal c'est tout frédéric
bizarre tout de même fait pas prendre la
défense du gouvernement je suis pas là
pour ça mais je suis là pour
effectivement poser des questions et
apporter la contradiction ce que vient
nous dire fabrice di vizio c'est
intéressant parce que voilà fallait
faire vite mais en même temps les
soignants demandent eux justement des
augmentations c'est très légitime de
leur part demande une augmentation des
lits et c'est vrai qu'une réforme
structurelle de l'hôpital par définition
bron ont beaucoup plus de temps alors
comment allier ces deux équilibre
correctement ciment de l'ordre ambition
c'est plutôt constructif j'ai créé
l'institut santé ya deux ans on a créé
un centre de recherche dédié à la
refondation on essaie d'apporter chacun
notre pierre à l'édifice parce que la
refonte du système de santé absolument
indispensable puisque l'on vit sur un
système qui a été créée il ya soixante
dix ans donc il n'y a absolument plus à
jour alors qu'on a parmi les meilleurs
soigner au monde
on allait à toutes les ressources qu'il
faut donc on est dans un énorme gâchis
le sentiment aujourd'hui que notre
système de santé défaillant et quand
même le signe d'un énorme gâchis dont il
faut avoir conscience
donc moi je je je je je m'active pour
essayer de participer à cette
refondation la déception que le
aujourd'hui ma de la déclaration du
premier ministre c'est qu'ils semblent
lui véritablement penser que le problème
est un problème uniquement de
rémunération et qu'il suffit de régler
rapidement pour que l'on puisse passer
un autre dossier
non le dossier de la santé c'est le
dossier du prochain quinquennat
c'est le dossier qui va prendre des
aller parce que c'est un système qu'il
faut remettre sur pied pour les 50 ans à
venir maintenant vous avez raison il ya
un problème de court terme qui est un
problème plus politique politiciens
qu'un problème est aussi qui qui est lié
au système de santé puisque on a vu que
l'hôpital ça a été dit par fabrice di
vizio de façon tout à fait juste on a vu
que s'il ya quelque chose qui a bien
tenu pendant cette crise du comics et
l'hôpital alors que le reste n'a pas
tenu parce que la vraie crise du système
de santé n'est pas l'hôpital
elle est par une défaillance totale de
la prise en amont du risque maladie ce
qu'on appelle la prévention ce qu'on
appelle les déterminants de santé une
médecine de ville qui est un train
véritablement de se désintégrer avec des
unes avec des territoires qui sont sens
en médecine de ville à un système médico
social qui est quand même à l'agonie
c'est là la vraie crise c'est pas à
l'hôpital public
l'hôpital public un problème de
reconnaissance du personnel soignant
mais croyez moi la vraie crise n'est pas
à l'hôpital public donc de laisser
entendre que havard ajoutant 7 milliards
d'euros
on va entre guillemets régler le
problème du système de santé
là c'est quelque chose qui est tellement
loin de la réalité quels que soient les
sensibilités qu'on peut avoir quelle que
soit la mémé ça c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement partagé parmi toutes les
sensibilités politiques
donc moi c'est ça ne que le politique
monsieur le président a rappelé le
monsieur président de la république
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur
nice de la santé surtout surtout ne pas
faire croire en français on va régler la
question du système de santé avec sept
ou huit milliards d'euros pour l'hôpital
public
fabrice di vizio le matière de d'olivier
véran à son passé c'est plutôt un bon
signal qui va dans le bon sens on les
personnels moi j'ai un problème avec le
maintien d'olivier verrons
j'ai un problème si vous voulez d'abord
il ya la présomption d'innocence notre
vivant il fait l'objet d'un procès
judiciaire mais je pense qu'à un moment
si vous voulez moi ce qui me perturbe et
olivier ferrand c'est qu'il est sous le
coup d'une information judiciaire qui
quand même touche à l'exercice même de
sa mission dans le cadre d'une épidémie
alors qu'il était en poste et il a eu
des déclarations pour le moins
malheureuse qui ont été relevées par les
médecins libéraux
et donc quand même je peux
raisonnablement m'interroger de savoir
si le poste de ministre de la santé ne
méritait pas mieux
dans un temps de reconstruction
précisément que finalement olivier
derand qui aujourd'hui est quand même
sous le coup d'une information
judiciaire
c'est qu'un ministre en exercice avec un
adulte à l'heure une mission normale
manqué de refondation de l'hôpital si
une deuxième vague arrive il va être
effectivement au premier large
est ce qu'aujourd'hui c'est vraiment la
bonne personne pour assumer ce rôle à
titre personnel je pense que non parce
que je pense que nous sommes une société
de symboles et que qui plus est à
presque vide et que symboliquement avoir
un ministre de la santé qui est sous le
coup d'une information judiciaire pour
effectivement sa gestion de la crise
c'est quand même un problème à mes yeux
c'est un vrai problème et il est allé
très loin olivier derand quand il dit
que les cabinets libéraux ont fermé dans
koh vidic c'est la raison pour laquelle
notamment ils ont pas une masse il va
très loin comme il va très très loin et
dans ce contexte on a un ministre qui a
toujours pas produit les bons de
commande de masques
donc on est quand même dans une
situation qui est inédite et pour moi je
pense que l'apaisement social mérité
quand même en toute quiétude quenum à ce
poste si vous voulez on peut pas à la
fois nommé jean castex premier ministre
olivier ferrand milles de la santé
gardez votre mix bachelot mise la
culture sans qu'un moment donné on se
dise légitimement médias un catho
qu'est-ce que les soignants ont donc
fait
ce gouvernement dont frédéric bizarre
sur sur ces nouvelles nominations ça
peut porter préjudice aux figures de la
de la santé ont finalement c'est une
bonne chose pour le ségur de la santé
c'est un sens de conserver un ministre
qui a aucun qui a démarré les
négociations
donc moi ça ça me choque pas maintenant
ce que ce qui serait souhaitable ces
colis et veron qui a été rapporteur des
différents projets de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale de ces dernières
années donc qui a été co constructeur de
la politique de santé depuis ces
dernières années et prennent conscience
que il faut vraiment prendre un virage
mais pas un virage idéologique
c'est un virage parce que le monde a
tellement changé sur le plan
épidémiologique sur le plan
démographique sur le plan technologique
que notre système qui a été excellent
sur le plan du soin au xxème siècle
devienne un système excellent 21e siècle
et pour ça il faut le transformer il
faut passer du soin la santé c'est à
dire qu'il faut enfin reconnaître que
les personnes bien portantes sont aussi
importantes que les personnes malades
système attend que les gens soient
malades pour les prendre en charge
on est tout à fait dans un système qui
était qui et archaïque et qui est très
bon dans son archaïsme quand les gens
sont malades mais ça ne suffit plus
aujourd'hui du fait du changement de
l'environnement
il faut on a en étouffer la démocratie
sanitaire on est dans un système qui a
totalement du rock rate is et qu'ils
aient décidé de l'avenue de ségur alors
qu'il faut un système qui partent des
territoires qui partent des besoins de
santé sont des choses quand même content
qu'on rabâche que l'on connaît dont on
connaît les solutions et de ce point de
vue c'est vrai que je n'entends jamais
olivier ferrand dire il va falloir qu'on
fasse différemment de ce qu'on a fait
ces 20 dernières années
il centre dans une continuité qui est
quand même une continuité dans le déclin
du système
si on ne change pas véritablement l
approche est l'état d'esprit par rapport
au système de santé qu'il faudra mettre
en place
fabrice division vous parlais tout à
l'heure de cette enquête judiciaire
évidemment ouverte par la cjr contre
olivier ferrand vous l'avez dit agnès
buzyn également edouard philippe neuf
plaintes recevables sur les 90 reçu par
la cour de justice de la république
s'est veut c'est beaucoup comment vous
un chiffre bas je peux pas le juger je
sais pas ce que contenaient les les
autres plaintes
ce que je sais c'est que apparemment un
certain nombre d'aidés toute façon pas
recevable parce que le formalisme est
assez exigeant en outre je pense que
n'ont été retenus si j'ai bien compris
que les plaintes qui vise l article 223
7 du code pénal
c'est à dire l'omission volontaire en
fait l'abstention volontaire et donc
toutes les attractions dont un
intentionnel ont été considérés comme
n'étant pas recevable du coup forcément
ça limitait considérablement le nombre
de plaintes mais ceci dit c'est pas très
étonnant si vous voulez c'est à dire que
on savait aussi je l'avais délire 10,1
que sur ces 84 plaintes y en avait
beaucoup qui était la manifestation
d'une colère la manifestation impulsive
une colère mais qui ne correspondaient
pas à une démarche juridique construite
et à un sens les celles qui
correspondent à une démarche juridique
construites ont été admises
dès lors le fondement des bons que les
faits étaient bons et donc c'est
légitime si vous voulez je ne suis pas
surpris outre mesure qu'on est de neuf
plaintes 84 ça dépend vraiment et il
semblait que procureur général semblait
dire d'ailleurs beaucoup émaner de
particulier sans avocat par exemple donc
le formalisme ne serait ce que ça
n'était pas respecté merci à tous les
deux frédéric bizarre fabrice sa
division d'avoir été avec nous pour os
décryptage merci à tous les deux et
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain point complet sur
l'actualité à 22h
[Musique]
la stratégie politique depuis pas mal
d'années encourage la fracture sociétale
pour éviter d'aborder les questions de
fond pour en remettre en cause la pensée
des groupes de pression pour moi
l'étude démontre la nocivité de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine au nom de la
peur de la mort
notre ministre a interdit immédiatement
son utilisation
le problème c'est que l'étude avait été
faite par des cardiologues sur la base
de données fournies par une société sacs
tissent dont certains les employés ont
des qualifications étonnant allant de
l'auteur de science-fiction à l'hôtesse
mannequin dans cette dictature de la
pensée unique
les technocrates et activiste et de
nombreux journalistes ne s'intéressent
qu'à la partie qui va dans leur sens et
censure ou dévalorise le reste on décide
de ce que le peuple doit penser
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer tout seul dans ses
cuisines et bains je me suis aperçu que
c'était bien plus difficile qu'avec une
équipe de 25 l'usiné autour pour nous
pour nos fournisseurs pour nos équipes
c'était essentiel d'ouvrir le plus tôt
possible beaucoup des mises de la vie ne
reprendra pas de la même façon je
n'adhère pas à cette théorie du monde
d'avant du monde d'après je crois que le
monde d'avant il était formidable et
qu'on a envie de le retrouver je pensais
que ça allait me rendre plus tolérante
et ça m'a rendu plus intolérant alors
par mois elle c'est la dimension vous
posez justement délirer autour d'un
dessert que j'ai appelé la pêche n'a pas
le bac
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après il serait aussi dynamique et
tonique que le monde d'avant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'eau
[Musique]
emmanuel macron a fixé quatre grands
axes de travail dans la reconstruction
du pays et le patriotisme républicain au
gouvernement qu'il a réuni pour la
première fois aujourd'hui lors du
conseil des ministres deux nouveaux
ministres
ferrals darmanin avec lui une première
journée mouvementée avec plusieurs
manifestations de militants féministes
qui appelle à sa démission en raison
d'accusations de violation l'emploi
geyer renard ou testés positifs au
coronavirus le président brésilien s'est
soumis à un test suite à la présence de
chantôme il dit recevoir un traitement
allaient roxy chloroquine et elle est
parfaitement bien
l'om est il souhaite un rapide
rétablissement le brésil qui est loin
d'en avoir terminé avec le comique 19 le
pays enregistrait plus de
nouveau bien c'est dernières 24 heures
l'assassinât de soliman y jugeait
illégale selon une experte de l'onu le
général iranien avait été tué en janvier
dernier sur le sol irakien par un drone
américain
un rapport mandaté par l'onu parle de
l'absence de menace imminente mettant en
danger la vie un nouveau désaveu pour
washington qui ne devrait pas arranger
sa relation avec téhéran
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rcf rend si
vous nous rejoignez tous les regards
sont désormais tournés vers le nouveau
gouvernement son premier conseil des
ministres a eu lieu dans l'après-midi
exercice connu pour beaucoup d'entre eux
qui ont gardé leur portefeuille comme
bruno le maire florence parly ou encore
jean yves le drian ils travailleront
maintenant avec huit nouveaux entrants
le premier ministre jean castex a donné
le tempo il veut aller vite
place au travail donc pour la nouvelle
formation
on fait le point avec notre reporter et
celle farges devant l'elysée après les
nominations hier place aux travaux
pratiques aujourd'hui avec le tout
premier conseil des ministres du
gouvernement castex la nouvelle équipe
composée de seize ministres de 14
ministres est délégué et d'un secrétaire
d'état s'est réunie à cet après midi
autour d' emmanuel macron pendant 1h45
le couple exécutif
macron à castex qui souhaite accélérer
la cadence et montrer que l'équipe est
opérationnel à l'issue du conseil
elle s'est tenu le traditionnel compte
rendu tenue pour la première fois par un
gabriel attal porte parole du
gouvernement à qui a évoqué une équipe
de combat et d'un rassemblement avec un
nouveau chemin à qui s'articule autour
de quatre grands axes la reconstruction
du pays
d'abord reconstruction économique social
environnemental et territorial et
culturel puis le patriotisme républicain
je vous propose d'écouter à ce propos
gabriella talent le deuxième axe de ce
nouveau chemin c'est le patriotisme
républicain pas république a parfois
trop manqué à manquer à ses propres
promesses et donc nous allons avancer
avec des objectifs clairs aller au bout
de notre ambition sur l'école qui a
démarré je le disais avec le
dédoublement des classes porté par jean
michel bancaire il nous faut poursuivre
dans ce mouvement
c'est un défi historique pour notre
jeunesse qui a vécu un moment
extrêmement difficile avec le
confinement et sur laquelle nous devons
continuer à investir et des annonces
seront faites autour de ce sujet pour
l'avenir de notre jeunesse
le porte parole du gouvernement à qui a
aussi évoqué la volonté du chef de
l'état d'avoir une politique plus à
lisible une ainsi qu'une politique
européenne forte noter enfin que jean
castex réunira ses ministres dans un
séminaire gouvernemental samedi matin né
en marge de la passation de pouvoir
entre christophe castaner et gérald
darmanin plusieurs féministes sont venus
manifester
une dizaine de personnes ont crié des
slogans et brandi des pancartes contre
le nouvel homme fort de la place beauvau
gérald darmanin qui je le rappelle est
visé par une plainte pour viol elles ont
été rapidement repoussés et empêcher de
se rapprocher par les forces de l'ordre
on aimerait déjà qu'ils écoutent les
associations notamment dans le cadre des
féminicides par exemple qu'il ya une
formation de la police en fait surtout
apprendre les pointes ça c'est une
demande qu'il y a je ne sommes pas
écoutés on a employé des moyens quand
même assez massive de collage et réseaux
sociaux
même à l'international le mouvement
décollage s'est beaucoup démocratisé et
aujourd'hui le gouvernement qui avait
annoncé sa volonté de faire de l'égalité
femmes-hommes la grande politique incana
nous montre l inverse par les actes et
pour gabriel attal le nouveau porte
parole du gouvernement le principe de la
présomption d'innocence s'applique à
gérald darmanin la question de les
investigations sur gérald darmanin sur
ce sujet moi ce que je veux dire de
manière très claire c'est que on ne peut
pas d'un côté sacraliser la présomption
d'innocence en toutes circonstances est
considéré que c'est un socle essentiel
de notre pays ce qui est notre cas je
crois et je l'espère à tous et
considérer qu'il y aurait des personnes
qui par la fonction qu'elle occupe ne
pourraient pas bénéficier cette
présomption d'innocence
il ya des investigations elles se
tiennent et c'est normal on est en état
de droit mais mais mais on peut pas
aller plus loin que ça en considérant
finalement parce qu'il ya des
investigations il y aurait il y aurait
d d impossibilité à exercer dans un
gouvernement
mais pour fatima benomar militants de
l'association féministe les effrontés la
nomination de gérald darmanin va à
l'encontre de ce qu'avait annoncé le
gouvernement
au moment du grenelle contre les
violences faites aux femmes le
gouvernement avait admis qu'ils avaient
deux grands secteurs où il y avait un
réel problème c'était la police et la
justice qui était dans le parcours des
femmes victimes de viols et de violences
conjugales et de violences sexuelles et
c'est parce que les policiers ne prenez
pas les plaintes parce que nous allions
des qualifiés le viol ont lutté
qualifiant en agression sexuelle parce
que ce sont des classements sans suite à
gogo faut savoir qu'en france au plus
haut niveau de l'état on admet qu a
qu'un pour cent des violeurs qui sont
condamnés et le premier remaniement
après le grenelle en cdd qu'il y allait
avoir des gestes forts c'est-à-dire au
moins à la tête de la police et de la
justice des personnes qui sont
sensibilisés sur ces questions là et là
on a exactement l'inversé on a comme
premier flic de france
un homme qui est accusé par deux femmes
de viol et pas n'importe quelle forme de
viol c'est-à-dire des femmes qui disent
qu'il a abusé de postes de pouvoir
en tant que maire et entente et
personnes en responsabilité à l'ump pour
monnayer entre guillemets contre des
rapports sexuels des services qu'elle
lui demander et on a de l'autre côté à
la tête par en tant que garde des sceaux
un homme ouvertement anti féministe je
vous passe les tirs à a2 profondément
sexiste des misogynes prelic
dupond-moretti l'homme aux 150 ha
quipements ce n'est pas une surprise de
voir un avocat garde des sources ce
qu'il est en revanche c'est de voir à
quel point sa nomination ne plaît pas au
syndicat majoritaire chez les magistrats
lui sm pour eux sont entrés au
gouvernement est tout simplement une
déclaration de guerre grégoire douce et
avec les mots spital monsieur eric
dupond moretti
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
c'est une annonce pour le moins
surprenante le visage d'eric
dupond-moretti n'est pas inconnu du
grand public associés à une multitude
d'affaires médiatique
cette figure célèbre de la justice
française manie l'art du contre-pied
tour à tour défenseur du couple balkany
bernard tapie jérôme kerviel ou encore
des sportives nikola karabatic et karim
benzema
celui qu'on surnomme acquittator est
plutôt du genre à aller à contre-courant
dans l'opinion majoritaire ce sobriquet
il le doit un palmarès fourni en
acquittements obtenus pour ses clients
plus de 150 au total la nomination du
successeur de nicole belloubet a de quoi
surprendre tant il entretient des
rapports tourmentée avec les
institutions 20 juin
dupond moretti dépose plainte contre x
mécontent d'avoir été mis sous
surveillance par le parquet national
financier une plainte désormais retiré
annonce l'elysée
sa nomination à la justice suscite des
réactions pour le moins mitigé pour
moraliser l'action politique lutter
contre le terrorisme et restaurer la
confiance de la police emmanuel macron
nomme ministre de la justice l'avocat
d'abdelkader meira ainsi que de
messieurs mme balkany et cahuzac
rappelons qu'un avocat peut toujours
choisir ses clients un gouvernement
libéral banal castaner belloubet honte
de l'intérieur de la justice enfin
démissionner darmanin dupond-moretti
doivent rétablir la dignité et d'honneur
félicitations à notre confrère eric
dupond moretti dans l'engagement dans la
profession n'est plus à démontrer
gageons que les avocats et la justice
retrouveront avec lui la place centrale
qu'ils doivent avoir dans notre
démocratie et notre état de droit
nommer une personnalité aussi clivante
et qui méprise à ce point les magistrats
c'est une déclaration de guerre à la
magistrature
quel est le message qu'entend plus le
ministre de la justice se trouve relégué
aussi loin dans l'ordre protocolaire le
mépris le plus total pour la justice au
lendemain des nominations eric dupond
moretti doit déjà faire face à la colère
des robes noires
à vis de la réforme des retraites le
nouveau ministre de la justice assure
qu'il sera le garde des sceaux du
dialogue ce n'est pas le ministère de la
guerre même si j'ai cru entendre ces
mots mais celui des libertés pendant
près de 36 ans j'ai sillonné la france
dont je connais tous les tribunaux
je le confesse je n'ai pas de la justice
une connaissance technocratique
je la connais humainement j'ai appelé
intimement
je la connais nicole charnellement
récemment interrogé sur ce qu'il ferait
s'il devenait garde des sceaux dupond
moretti avait déjà quelques idées
concrètes
d'abord il faut qu'on sépare le siège du
parquet pour moi c'est impératif
je fais le ménage là-dedans de façon
très très très clair je fais un système
de responsabilité des juges parce que
les juges ne sont pas responsables de ce
qu'ils font aujourd'hui ce sont les
seuls dans notre société ne pas être
responsable il faut réunir des juges et
fait une réforme non pas contre eux mais
avec eux avec des grands juges qui font
l'unanimité parmi les autres dossiers
brûlants prévu à son nouvel agenda la
réforme du droit pénal concernant la
délinquance environnementale ou encore
le nouveau code pénal pour mineurs
initiée par sa prédécesseure
on vient d'apprendre c'est officiel les
etats-unis se retire de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé ce après avoir
suspendu leur participation son
financement il ya plusieurs semaines
c'est ce que l'administration entre up
annoncé au congrès américain ce soir la
sortie sera effective dans un délai d'un
an le 6 juillet 2021 donc et le
président jacques bolle sonar au testé
positif aux coronavirus aujourd'hui lui
qui a pourtant toujours minimisé la
pandémie en début de semaine il a même
opposé son veto à des articles de la loi
sur l'utilisation de masques dans les
lieux publics
il a finalement été contraint de se
faire tester suite à des symptômes
le brésil est le deuxième pays au monde
le plus touché valentin carpentier avec
emilie goût gâche jaillir vol sonar eau
contaminée par le cos vide 19 le
président brésilien de 65 ans l'a
annoncé lors d'un entretien accordé à
plusieurs chaînes de télévision
moi par exemple si je n'avais pas fait
le test et bien je ne connaîtrai pas le
résultat
et il s'est avéré positif le chef d'état
avait longtemps minimisé la maladie mais
il avait fini par prendre quelques
précautions à la suite de symptômes dus
coronavirus chose rare il s'était même
montré avec un masque sur le visage
avant d'effectuer un test de dépistage
du coc vite 19 quelques heures avant
cette intervention gr bol senard a
opposé son veto à deux articles de la
loi sur l'utilisation des masques dans
les lieux publics
un assouplissement qui a lieu en même
temps que la réouverture des bars
restaurants et salons de beauté à sao
paulo capitale économique du pays dans
une nouvelle étape de déconfinement la
ville sort d'une quarantaine qui a duré
une centaine de jours les commerces
pourront ouvrir quotidiennement durant
six heures seulement à 40 % de leur
capacité d'accueil des réouvertures cinq
jours après celle de rio de janeiro qui
enchante commerçants et clients
je meurs vraiment envie de sortir ça
vous donne un sentiment de liberté vous
savez être à la maison pendant trois
mois sans sortir pour quoi que ce soit
et difficile
la plupart des clients de travail à
domicile la plupart d'entre eux
travaillent encore à domicile et en
raison des horaires réduits
ce n'est pas bon pour nous non plus car
on s'occupe des clients la nuit on
travaillait de 9 à 7 heures avant et
maintenant nous sommes ici de 11 à 4
heures donc c'est un peu difficile
si le pays se dé confine la pandémie est
toujours présente en termes de
contamination et de décès le brésil est
toujours le deuxième pays le plus touché
au monde derrière les états unis et pour
hervé théry docteur en géographie
professeur à l'université de sao paulo
jaillir wolson arrow et ses partisans
sont dans le déni il est vraiment dans
le délit est dans le défi fait partie
des six pays au monde qui sont dans le
déni il ya trois baies ya le burundi le
brésil et la biélorussie le nicaragua et
j'en oublie deux autres médias que six
pays au monde qui font ça et il est
dedans et donc il est un délire on a
aussi appelé ça le club des autruches
dans la majorité dans tous les sondages
disent qu'ils sont absolument convaincus
qu'il faut rester confiné ce qu'on
entend le plus c'est la minorité de 25
5% des partisans inconditionnels de boxe
au now qui font du bruit des
manifestations mais dans mes collègues
dans mes amis dans ma belle famille les
gens restent confinés ils sont pas fous
et donc ce qu'on voit le plus c'est le
sait là les gens qui défient et puis
d'autre part les gens pauvres qui n'ont
pas le choix qui doivent sortir tous les
jours pour gagner de quoi se nourrir et
nourrir leurs enfants et donc ne peuvent
absolument pas appliquer le confinement
dans tous les gens qui sont dans la rue
sont pas là par des fils y en a qui sont
là par des fils à la capitale de
madagascar à nouveau placé en
confinement en raison d'un regain de la
propagation du coronavirus le
gouvernement a décidé de limiter des
poches épidémie 40,1 arrive et sa
banlieue nord pendant le week-end 4000
militaires ont été déployés dans les
rues de la capitale malgache pour faire
respecter les consignes durant une
quinzaine de jours
les derniers chiffres sont inquiétants
quelques jours la barre des 3000
personnes infectées a été franchie en 33
morts et 45
patients en réanimation
je suis vendeuse de sacs en plastique on
nous chasse et nous ne pouvons pas
vendre alors que l'argent ne tombe pas
du ciel
j'ai déjà vendu mais marmite mondes rats
je n'ai plus rien à manger rien à vendre
où va-t-on aller vous savez des petits
gens souffrent ils sont tout le temps
confinés
je propose qu'on leur donne la
possibilité de travailler pour gagner de
l'argent
cela soulagerait un peu mais là le seul
moyen qu'on trouve c'est de les menacer
laissez les gens vendre parce qu'ils
sont en difficulté
moi je suis une veuve et je suis sans
ressources les responsables sociaux
doivent regarder de près notre cas parce
que les gens sont confinés mais il y en
a qui doivent sortir pour des raisons de
santé de décès ou des obligations pour
nous ou nos enfants et pour tarik
mallard habitants dans arrivent les
habitants n'ont pas toujours la
possibilité de se protéger comme il le
faudrait alors je pense que
objectivement les malgaches ont connu un
certain relâchement au moment de la
crise les dirigeants du pays n'ont pas
forcément été plus clair possible sur la
dangerosité de la situation et puis
encore une fois c'est l'économie
informelle
la plupart des habitants du pays n'ont
pas le choix que de travailler pour se
nourrir et au jour le jour
donc au bout d'un moment ils sont
obligés de nous sortir de leur maison et
de se mêler à la foule dans la capitale
on peut voir que les gens portent des
masques respectent les mesures barrières
dès qu'on s'éloigne un petit peu on voit
que c'est moins le cas
mais sur place et dans les entreprises
locales ou les gens sont obligés de
travailler il y a des il ya des règles
qui sont mises en place pour que les
malgaches respectent les mesures
barrières en australie aussi sarr
confine les autorités du pays annoncent
un retour du confinement à melbourne
elle plus de cinq millions de personnes
ont reçu l'ordre ce mardi de rester chez
eux pour une durée d'au moins six
semaines
191 nouveaux cas ont été détectés en 24
heures ce qui rend difficile le traçage
des personnes infectées
les élèves suivront à nouveau un
enseignement à distance tandis que les
restaurants et les cafés ne pourront
plus servir que des plats à emporter
l'état de victoria a fermé ses
frontières les hollandais du reste du
pays
ces chiffres de nouveaux cas d'infection
sont particulièrement ingérable il est
simplement impossible avec de tels taux
d'infection que les personnels qui sont
au contact et les ressources physiques
nécessaires
peu importe d'où ils viennent et quel
équipement importe pour continuer à
lutter contre le virus et à l'eau
tenir sans que des décisions
significatives soient prises si nous
devions échoué dans l'adoption de telles
mesures alors nous n'aurons pas 200
nouveaux cas par jour mais bien plus et
cela deviendrait vite une spirale
totalement hors de contrôle
mais l'épidémie qui s'accélère selon l'
oms le pic ne serait pas encore atteint
les états unis restent le pays le plus
touché
l'iran annonce un triste record avec 200
morts en 24 heures la situation se
stabilise timidement en europe
le point en images
où
[Musique]
je
oh
[Musique]
[Rires]
l'assassinât de qassem soleimani par les
états unis sur le sol irakien jugé
illégal c'est ce qu'a déclaré une
rapporteur de l'onu lors d'un entretien
accordé à l'agencé reuters un nouveau
désaveu donc pour washington qui ne
devrait pas arranger sa relation avec
téhéran ont fait le point avec walid
bennani l attaque avait eu lieu le 3
janvier dernier lors d'une frappe de
drones menées par les états unis
le général iranien qassem suleimani et
neuf autres personnes sont tuées
la maison blanche avait justifié cet
assassinat ciblé en déclarant qu'il
préparait des offensives contre des
américains dans la région
six mois plus tard selon l'onu ou
ashington n'a pas apporté de preuves
suffisants d'une attaque en cours ou
imminente contre ses intérêts permettant
de justifier une telle décision
il s'agit d'un moment critique pour le
monde possiblement d'un virage
concernant le recours aux drones
le conseil de sécurité est absent sur ce
sujet tout comme la communauté
internationale qui reste majoritairement
silencieuse selon la rapporteure l'armée
américaine a violé la charte de l'onu
l'expert des droits de l'homme appellent
à plus de régulation et de ses vérités à
propos des frappes de drones
déjà après la tacc l'organisation
internationale pointé du doigt les états
unis aient critiqué l' acte perpétré par
washington sur fond chéri à des saisies
pour la syrie il s'agit d'un acte
flagrant est évident d'assassinât
d'agression et d'exécution comme vous
l'avez dit d'une nation étrangère sur
une terre étrangère à un moment où tout
le monde cherche à apaiser les tensions
dans la région et non à les augmenter
expliqué aussi c'est navrant de voir la
grande puissance des états unis
utilisant les mêmes moyens que les gangs
pour tuer quelqu'un to kill samba des
gains
le général soliman ni qui dirigeait
l'unité d'élite iranienne al-qods joue
un rôle important dans la montée en
puissance de l'iran est dans le conflit
contre les forces américaines sa mort
avait eu un impact majeur dans les
relations déjà tendues entre washington
et téhéran l'iran avait riposté à cet
assassinat par des tirs de missiles
contre des bases irakiennes abritant des
soldats américains
le rapport de l'onu sur l'attaqué contre
soliman y sera présenté ce jeudi au
conseil des droits de l'homme lasserre
et m et 10 journalistes iraniens rfi
pointe du doigt le rapport de l'expert
mandaté par le conseil des droits de
l'homme de l'onu concernant la mort du
général iranien soit lémanique
le rapport de madame calme heures
portent sur nous âge des drones dans les
assassinats ciblés mais la moitié de son
rapport concerne seulement le cas de
l'ancien chef de l'international des
milices chiites fondée par terran est
dirigé par lui même tous rangs des
années or depuis l'instauration de
pratiques d'assassiner ciblé par dron
après les attentats du 11 septembre 2001
plusieurs milliers de personnes et pour
la plupart des civils et en particulier
au pakistan et en afghanistan ont perdu
de cette façon laure vit son que vous ne
savez loué nous et encore moins moi d'un
calamar malgré les déments pressants des
victimes et organisations de défense de
droits de l'homme dénoncent ces
pratiques la direction israël à présent
les territoires palestiniens également
les manifestations contre le projet
controversé d'annexion une partie de la
cisjordanie se multiplient
éclaircissements avec walid bénin un
cratère dans le sol dévastés et des
dégâts matériels multiples symboles du
conflit israélo palestinien
dimanche soir les deux camps se sont
rendus coup pour coup
pour le plus grand désarroi de leur
population par mattia la dernière fois
non comme vous pouvez le voir les avions
militaires israéliens nous sur voler de
nuit et nous avons été surpris lorsque
les miss
donc commencé à s'abattre sur nous il
semble qu'il croyait que c'était abriter
les membres de la résistance des
missiles ou des armes mais c'est
malheureusement ce que nous constatons
est ce que nous avons l'habitude de
subir de la part des forces d'occupation
jadot a man nano à l'alerté là de son
côté le gouvernement israélien s'est
tout de suite justifié en réponse aux
trois roquettes tirées vers israël plus
tôt dans la soirée
nos forces aériennes viennent de frapper
une installation souterraine des
terroristes du hamas à gaza
nous tenons le hamas pour responsable à
hébron les tensions sont également vives
là aussi des manifestants palestiniens
se heurtent aux soldats israéliens un
regain de tensions liées à la promesse
de benyamin nétanyahou d'opérer le 1er
juillet à l'annexion de pans entiers de
la cisjordanie dans le cadre du plan de
paix proposé par donald trump présenté
en janvier dernier à washington
mais pour l'heure pas d'annoncé
officielle cela aurait pu avoir lieu
mercredi 1er juillet mais les choses
doivent encore se préciser avec le
gouvernement américain
il n'y a pas eu d'accord complet sur les
zones où la souveraineté israélienne
sera appliqué un plan de paix rejetées
par l'autorité palestinienne ainsi que
les habitants des territoires occupés
qui multiplie les manifestations exemple
le 1er juillet à gaza la résistance doit
commencer dès maintenant car israël ne
reconnaîtra rien qui s'apparente au
compromis ou à la négociation
israël ne craint que la force et nous
devons nous unir pour lui résister
l'administration trump dit être en
pourparlers avec tous les pays de la
région pour finaliser un processus des
plus controversés effet la fin de cette
édition merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
point sur l'actualité de me mettre un 7
heures du matin heure française quand à
moi j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
à 20 heures demain soir
[Musique]
le général guisan en fait été
effectivement